for many reasons it's uh been a dark day
it's been a very tumultuous past i guess
a couple of weeks couple of months in
afghanistan and today
you know mid-morning we get some of the
most horrifying news that there was an
attack
uh
we're now getting confirmation up to
so far 13 u.s service members have lost
their lives and this and there's some
crazy stuff i read look i want to say
with the breaking news it's hard to know
what all the details are different
sources are giving different numbers the
most up-to-date that i've been able to
find says 13 u.s service members have
lost their lives i read one story that
said
that the u.s had warned the american
troops in at the airport in kabul
that there was a strong possibility of a
terror attack
in the morning the uk uh the uk and the
us advised all people especially their
citizens to avoid the area
and these
brave men and women
stayed doing their jobs knowing being
told that there is a very strong
likelihood of a terror attack
now we're learning that they lost their
lives
of course there's a there's a lot going
around um republicans are absolutely
coming after biden on this one he
botched the whole thing he abandoned
bagram air force base before evacuating
civilians and now we're learning that
there's a wild wild estimate of the
americans that are still in kabul some
say it's only a few thousand apparently
some reports say it could even be in the
tens of thousands maybe 30 000 we don't
know for sure and the us government uh
biden administration is not actually
confirming these numbers but my friends
i hope you are ready to be angry
uh because it's not my intent to make
you angry every day but we have
reporting now from politico that the u.s
gave the names of american citizens and
afghan allies to the taliban
telling them like here's the people that
we want out
one defense official said they just put
those people on the kill list
this is bad
it's bad and i'm sure i i feel like
we're going to be in this conversation
for quite a bit apparently glenn beck
has personally traveled down there this
is crazy stuff um you know i will we'll
talk all about it but man that is
uh
mad respect absolutely absolutely
tremendous respect so we're going to get
into this and just
we got other stories
we do but we definitely got to talk
about this so joining us today is senior
commentary for the washington examiner
beckett adams thanks for having me you
want to just give a quick introduction
for yourself yeah i do see in your
commentary for the washington examiner i
enjoy especially covering politics but
mostly uh keep an eye on what the media
is up to right on right on cool dig it
man hey we have cat is that a captain's
uniform yes uh reporting to the bridge
tim
i'm here i'm wearing a star trek this is
the next generation star trek red shirt
so i'm not the first guy to get sucked
down
i'm actually one of the commanders so
get ready
awesome
i'm excited for tonight's conversation
but i am disturbed by what's been going
on so hopefully we can get all the way
to the bottom of it before we get
started head over to timcast.com become
a member and you will get access to the
exclusive tim cast irl members segments
that we put up monday through thursday
and you'll also get an ad free
experience and you will sleep well
knowing that you are supporting fierce
and independent journalism because we
actually have a bunch of independent
journalism um i should say on the ground
reporting that we are producing we just
had a reporter in new york city covering
a union protest against vaccine mandate
so if you want to support more work like
that become a member at timcast.com
don't forget to like this video
subscribe to this channel leave us a
good review on podcasts
whatever
share it with your friends let's uh
let's just quickly go into the more
serious nature of what's happening
because we have uh here's here's a story
uh
this is uh one of the most recent
stories we've been able to find abc 7
reporting at 7 pm 13 u.s service members
killed in kabul airport attacks
biden says attackers will pay we will
not forgive we will not forget we will
hunt you down and make you pay biden
said
two suicide bombers and gunmen attacked
crowds of afghans flocking to kabul's
airport thursday transforming a scene of
desperation into one of horror in the
waning days of an airlift for those
fleeing the taliban takeover the attacks
killed at least 60 afghans and 13 u.s
troops afghan and u.s officials i think
one of the most harrowing things
i heard was a
man who was an interpreter for the
marine corps
called into fox news and said that after
the blast there was a you know
five-year-old little girl that he was
trying to resuscitate and she died in
his arms
this didn't have to happen
why why are we in this mess no this had
to happen i
so much of the criticism that has been
directed at the bite administration
which by the way they've tried to
deflect
by conflating criticism for how we are
withdrawing
with the
cr very sort of non-existent criticism
that we should have never left the main
argument isn't we shouldn't leave
afghanistan i think most people actually
do support that a lot of polling shows
that especially recent polling the
criticism is for how we have done it
in a week since this has happened it has
been clear that everything they have
done has been made up as they go there
was no plan they claimed they planned
for all contingencies clearly they did
not they evacuated the military before
they evacuated our allies and civilians
in that debt of night no
and they didn't they didn't inform the
field commander at bagram base by the
way they didn't tell the afghani
commander they just irish goodbye
overnight
after 20 years it's like a bad boyfriend
um
so one thing that i i hear repeatedly
when i criticize or i talk about this on
social media or write about it or these
kind of you know the twitter biden
stands respond oh could you could you be
doing it better yes yes i could number
one don't
you you evacuate your civilians first
leave your military there as a rear
guard then you take out your combat
troops this is so don't close down
bagram it has two airstrips it's also
secluded and and strategically situated
instead they've bottlenecked everyone in
an international airport in kabul that's
surrounded by the taliban and we are now
completely dependent on whether or not
the taliban will pretty please let our
people live it's it's how many people in
kabul five million or or something like
that roughly i'd have to double check
but so it's a very dense urban populated
area and now we're asking our soldiers
and marines and everyone else over there
to essentially ferry these people to
safety despite the fact they're
completely surrounded this needs to be
stressed to all of the people who are
desperate to say it's not biden's fault
first thing i'll give you is when they
say it's george w bush fault i go all
right well to a certain jury i would
agree with that but
donald trump had a peace deal and a plan
for for for the evacuation for the pull
out and
yeah i don't think joe biden had a plan
no that's the thing too is like look we
can say trump's plan was garbage we can
say was ill-advised we could say was
stupid that doesn't matter biden is not
beholden to it he's a grown-ass
president he can make his own decisions
and he has shown repeatedly has no
problem overturning trump executive
actions trump policies or anything else
related to trump he ran on the fact that
he would overturn everything so the idea
that because he's been striking this
bizarre uh uh tone where it's
paradoxical where he says no yeah i made
the decision because i care about
america also my hands are tied what can
i do but this is this
already we have we got to break this
down and make sure everybody understands
this the original deadline was may 1st
you should not in the middle of the
night skip out on your strategic air
force base which is i believe about 45
miles outside of kabul
that it's got what two runways two
runways yeah so
i mean the first thing i started reading
when i'm reading from the opinions of
national security experts military
experts in these in these various op-eds
why did they in the middle of the night
abandon
the the base along with our resources
our weapons just the the black hawk
helicopters
and then say okay
now now for everybody who's still there
if you want to leave go to the airport
why
that i'm just i'm confused i'm genuinely
confused because let me just stress this
point
either they're really really dumb or
they did it on purpose this is something
we keep coming back to where you you
know the old saying is never a tribute
malice to that which can be uh explained
simply by stupidland's razor thank you
my favorite but you're looking at this
is how we left military aircraft which
now the taliban have and they are almost
certainly going to sell that to the
chinese or russians to disseminate and
study and make their own versions we
left hundreds of guns we left millions
of dollars we left trucks
and then again
taking military out first doesn't make
any sense you look at this and you go
why and how i keep getting stuck on that
and this sort of the nonsensical
approach that biden has taken to this
every step of the way is we had to get
out and then when the taliban came and
overran the country nobody saw this was
would happen then the bombs go off today
and essentially it's well you know this
is why we have to leave and also
we have to leave and also send in more
troops because we now need to go get the
people who did this what is there a plan
where where is the political commentary
gone from what a couple days ago it was
this is literally trump's plan it's
trump's fault now they're saying bombs
go off all the time in afghanistan
that's why we're leaving
but so it goes to the point like who
cares if this is trump's thing you are
president now today he was asked at his
press conference uh president biden was
if he takes full responsibility for the
dead marines and the navy uh medic the
corpsman and he answered um not even
loosely paraphrasing i take full
responsibility but remember this was
trump's plan that's what he said he did
say that he was responding to peter
ducey at fox news trump's plan was not
to leave in august right
first that's the other thing to point
out is that he keeps saying i am tied to
what trump did they already blew through
the deadline established by the trump
administration and the point we keep
coming back to is trump's plan didn't
involve shuttering bagram getting the
military out first and then abandoning
u.s nationals and
our allies that was never in the trump
plan
i don't i i i it's hard for me to
believe that this dumb to be complex
because
you know that if you pull the military
up before your the civilians and you
abandon an air force base you know this
is going to happen
so i mean look we keep coming back is it
stupidity because they say we didn't
have any intelligence general miley said
we didn't have anything indicating that
the taliban would essentially retake the
entire country within seven days the
intelligence community's saying
otherwise somebody's this is like the
the line from the old dire straits song
is that two men say they're jesus one of
them's got to be wrong that's what this
feels like okay somebody's not telling
the truth right now there gotta be
hearing something i mean they got they
knew of course they knew they were ready
to take the country in seven days they
they'd known that
we were evacuating for like eight months
they've been ready for this moment no
but we weren't supposed to pull
logistics and support for for the
afghans yeah they smelled blood and they
seized the opportunity well there were
videos going back uh a month or two ago
where the afghan commandos were fighting
back and then when they there's this
video it's horrifying they run out of
ammo so they surrender
and the taliban comes in and executes
them all films it all puts it on the
internet
so they didn't immediately just say we
give up no
the biden administration abandoned them
as you mentioned didn't even tell the
the was it the commander the afghan
commander he was the airfield uh
commander there
yeah at bagram he was the bagram
commander of the afghan army i'm looking
at a satellite image of bagram and kabul
how who in their right mind would think
that that
evacuating bagram would make any sense
if you look people yeah they're like in
a valley together kabul and bagram
surrounded by mountains like defensible
location why would they why would they
abandon that airstrike the only way you
can get to that airstrip is with trucks
or with an uh what's the word i'm
looking for with an air force neither of
which well taliban have trucks but they
well they have an air force no they do
because we abandoned bagram uh this is
the thing biden also claimed today that
he was advised by his top commanders and
military advisors that bagram could be
left because it didn't provide much of a
strategic output so like again i don't
want to jump on the impeach train or
whatever too soon but at this point
there need to be hearings especially now
that american blood has been shed which
i just want to clarify one of the more
really irritating and insidious
narratives that has been kind of
bubbling up in the press right now is
well you know not a lot of americans
have died yeah what about our afghan
allies we're being hunted they're being
executed they're being their homes are
being you know door-to-door they're
being dragged out in the street they're
being tortured that doesn't matter just
as long as american blood's not [ __ ] and
now and now they're saying
well you know the bombs go off it
happens all the time and of course
that's why we're getting out in the
first place it's not biden's fault no
i'll tell you what i said um what many
people said what almost every single
person we've had on this show has said
it is so such common sense
abandoning american citizens in in kabul
abandoning bagram air force base
you better prepare yourself for what's
to come the next several days when we
start seeing the blood of americans and
our allies now
what we're seeing here
man it's like it's got getting punched
in the gut because we knew it was bad
already and we are i kind of feel like
in the past few days i was thinking like
wow biden screwed this one up but
hearing that they were securing the the
the airport and they were getting out i
was like okay he botched this americans
are going to be stranded
but maybe this ends at the very least
without reaching this level like i
didn't i didn't part of me i guess
wanted to hold out thinking like we're
not going to see you know bombs going
off at the airport i i'm i mean i guess
i'll just disagree i thought at the
moment that they bottlenecked themselves
in kabul it's surrounded by the taliban
we're completely at the mercy i'm what
i'm saying
emotionally
i was i was sitting here thinking like
it's going to be okay
like the americans are in trouble that i
get our allies they're in there but i
have a feeling like there's a chance
that we're gonna we're gonna at least
just taper off here it's not gonna
escalate to that point and it was i
think it was me being i was just
naively hopeful well but also like i was
saying before the show too the taliban i
think the taliban wants to be recognized
legitimately as the government of
afghanistan so they're willing to play
ball here and and make sure these people
get out safely but there's lots of rogue
elements with explosives that want to
kill well isis k has claimed
responsibility for the bombing today
which apparently isis k is the off
branch of the old isis but to your point
i i think a lot of us are gonna have to
prepare ourselves emotionally mentally
spiritually whatever
uh for if there are americans left
behind which i guess
i should add right now the white house
is very clearly signaling that they they
themselves believe americans will be
left behind they will be captured and we
will see happen to them most likely what
isis has done to their prisoners they
line them up in their orange suits and
they make propaganda out of them it's
worse than that
my friends i hope you are prepared for
the next story we have for you and i
hope you're prepared to sit i hope
you're sitting down for this
with the amount of people that are
estimated to be trapped in afghanistan
be it afghan allies even the citizens
but american citizens especially who we
have a responsibility to as our as our
you know
our brothers and sisters our community
as well as our afghan allies for sure
and to humanity in general
there's estimates between a thousand two
thousand the low end where they're like
oh there's about a thousand or two
thousand left of american citizens we
gotta evacuate some are saying that it
was you know nbc news report fifteen
thousand then they evacuated about four
and a half thousand so it might be ten
thousand
when we hear and i want you to remember
this that there are american hostages i
want you to remember what the biden
administration did
from politico
u.s officials provided taliban with
names of americans and afghan allies to
evacuate quote basically they just put
all those afghans on a kill list said
one one official one defense official i
don't see why that would be
untrue for the americans biden did this
with vladimir putin remember that he was
like hey here's the list of things we
don't want you to attack and they're
like thanks for the hit list of your
most important infrastructure now
they're coming out and being like here
are the people we really care about like
oh so the ransom's double day or not
even the people we care about hey by the
way here are these people
these people have been hiding they've
been begging for help it was actually my
my old buddy from washington examiner uh
phil wegman who's now with real clear he
was the one who asked the president
today at the press conference about this
report he says can you comment on and
the president essentially confirmed it
saying there may be such lists being
given to the taliban but i'm not sure
which is again that doesn't inspire a
lot of confidence in me that the
commander-in-chief apparently doesn't
know what's going on over there we've
seen the taliban beating people there's
a video of an australian man he's being
beaten he's covered in blood the taliban
can claim whatever they want but they
look the the leadership like you
mentioned just previously ian that they
want to be seen as they do want to be
seen as a legitimate government they're
calling themselves the islamic emirate
of afghanistan they don't want to be
just this rogue element the taliban they
want to be the government but they can't
control their own people right stuff
gets leaked look that list is going to
get leaked look even if they want to be
a legitimate government i think the fact
that we're losing sight of the fact that
it's the fanatic death cult
and we are now completely at their mercy
we are look i i can i can get down this
road later
we are the greatest country the biggest
superpower
i love america and we are completely
beholden to the whims of fnatic death
cult in afghanistan by choice
choice and the fact that there's a
question about whether this
administration won't move earth in
heaven to save its its own you know
citizens any country or government that
doesn't make every possible effort to
rescue its own people is not a country
that deserves to be won i got to read
you this paragraph
u.s officials in kabul gave the taliban
a list of names of american citizens
green card holders and afghan allies to
grant entry into the militant controlled
outer perimeter of the city's airport a
choice that's prompted outrage behind
the scenes from lawmakers and military
officials it seems like the biden
administration is
treating these people like
any other country or government when
they literally just stormed in killed a
bunch of afghan security forces started
taking over cities and they're like
yeah here here's a list of names for
your checkpoints do you think that the
taliban checkpoints are legitimate
checkpoints where they're going to be
like oh yes an american passport right
this way sir or they're going to be like
we got an american okay right that way
sir maybe to your point they might for
the americans because they don't want to
start another another match who knows if
biden will actually make good on his
threat you know if that isis k will be
met with swift retribution those afghan
allies those people are as good as that
the taliban will make an example out of
them oh yeah they those people don't
have a chance now they know where they
are and they know they're coming this is
the one thing that i think might might
naively be giving me hope that the
taliban is scared you go you you start
you start going after these american
citizens and you're going to get you're
going to give them an excuse for
re-entry and they want the americans
gone they want us out right the afghans
who are staying behind
well they're the they're the apostates
they're they're refugees they should be
admitted status refugee status our
allies oh absolutely the translators the
families of the translators the fact
that we didn't get them out first what
were we what did they we knew this was
going to happen we knew the taliban
would come after these people anyone
with a target we saw this in iraq after
isis came out i got it my brother served
in iraq as a us marine and one of the
first things isis did when they came to
power and started marauding through the
middle east is they killed anyone who
worked with the united states marines so
a lot of guys my brother worked with are
now dead
there's precedent for this
but where we're at right now is that u.s
officials actually gave the names of
these people to the taliban that that
that's a kill list that i agree with
defense official like we can say we're
crossing our fingers
that the taliban has enough control
they're going to say get these americans
out of here before we cause more trouble
but this list of afghan citizens who
worked with them
bad they're done i mean by an
administration in this regard i think is
correct and is that we have shared
interest with the taliban we want to
leave they want us out so they may play
ball to a degree but the fact that here
we are hoping and praying please fanatic
death cult play ball i mean this we put
ourselves in this the biggest most
powerful country in the world aside from
maybe china is put itself in this
position and now we're just hoping and
praying but i'm telling you you know
those afghan allies they're as good as
dead you know how we put ourselves in
this position how trump was anti-elected
could you just explain that
there was no enthusiasm for joe biden in
the election none it was like 20 or
something enthusiasm for donald trump
was in the 90s enthusiasm against trump
was also very very high
and so this is what happens
when you say
we will literally vote for anything
because the orange man is bad
we had a man uh in joe biden who
couldn't talk so they made up that he
had a stutter you go watch videos from
joe biden when he was in the center he
doesn't have a stutter he never
maybe he was a little kid i guess fine
now they're claiming that his inability
to speak his his memory failings oh it's
just uh he's got a stutter stopped being
mean to him no no
people were willing to elect a man who
was old and incapable simply because
they hated trump
and i i mentioned this the other day i i
genuinely believed there would at least
be adults in there i'm like okay well
you know this happened but there's some
there's going to be some adults in the
room who are at least going to be like
you know when grandpa falls asleep i'll
i'll take this over and we'll we'll
finish up these documents and get a plan
ready and just you know wheelchair him
into the sun with a little burlap
blanket on his lap
no
they didn't and now now i kind of
understand what's really going on this
administration that biden's at the
meeting and he mutters and stumbles and
they all just kind of look at each other
and go whatever because all i care about
is me where's kamala harris when all
this goes down don't look at me she's
gone
so now i i genuinely believe that in
this administration with joe biden
millie
you know uh kamala harris
they don't know they don't care they're
probably just thinking like hey man i'm
not going to do anything that puts me in
grants me the responsibility for this
one
so if biden mutters and falls asleep
we're going to say fine because then
when it all goes belly up his fault not
ours
instead of being adults in the room and
being like biden abandoning an air force
base for an embassy is a bad idea mark
milly what did he say he said i was
ordered to guard the embassy did you
maybe just think um mr president we have
to guard the air force base how are we
gonna how are we gonna evacuate people
no he was just like you got it right
white rage
right i mean these are career
bureaucrats someone like kamala harris
isn't going to
risk everything she's climbed her way to
the top to get in order to tell by to
know in order to save 20 000 people yeah
she's not going to but is it really
their career are they really that craven
i mean to me this is one of those things
i'm trying to think of like a parallel i
know it's too dark
[Laughter]
it's
pretty dark well okay catholic sex abuse
is such a clear-cut thing that the
church should be fighting i'm a roman
catholic by the way so i'm not just
dumping on the catholic church the fact
that it is struggling to deal with what
is clearly a vile and evil thing and
it's turned into like you know it's
difficult sometimes no no this is so
easy how are you struggling with this
likewise in a different thing that's
dark it's very dark let's get back to
the administration no but it's something
like that it was like how are you
struggling with the question of getting
every american out this is so easy this
is so basic every major great
civilization has put a premium on its
own people and the fact that they're
actually using language the one thing
watch this
jen sackey and all of them are saying
using that weird phrase that terminology
americans who wanted to leave right
they're already laying the groundwork
for the americans who are going to be
left behind because they can claim they
didn't want to leave actually the
president said that today in his press
conference he said there were a lot who
didn't want to leave because they got
family and the thing is once america
pulls out and taliban takes over who is
going to double check that claim a bunch
of american journalists are going to fly
into taliban control afghanistan this is
priorities
what is the what what has the blind
administration prioritized nation
building
that's it
so when
when they decide they're going to be
getting out american citizens are not
their priority at all it's just this was
our priority we are leaving fine
everything else we don't give it we
don't get but how can not be no look
let's put the moral aspect the way that
it's morally decrepit that they are
dancing around this issue and hemming
and hawing on the issue of saving
americans and afghan allies let's look
at the political issue this is going
there's this doesn't go away i know uh
reuters reported reported recently that
the white house strategy is essentially
to just wait this out they think people
will forget about it after it comes and
goes yeah no
this is going to be so much worse first
of all it already is worse than saigon
and saigon didn't have people with
cameras in their pockets everywhere you
had a couple of major news wires taking
photos everyone is going to see this and
it's i'm telling you if americans are
left and they're captured and they're
made into propaganda tools and killed
and executed you don't lit you you don't
weather that that no he's got he's got
to resign no he res and then you have
president kamala i know
i tweeted that i said with all the talk
about impeaching joe biden which would
you prefer president biden or president
harris
most people said president biden i know
right can i just take the arsenic
somebody said uh
don't don't forget to include pelosi
because if you get kamala i don't i
don't see grounds for impeaching kamala
well it turns into this whole weird
thing where the senator's already split
so i don't even think she gets the vice
president because that that's a lopsided
vote that's a whole weird thing on it so
that's a parliamentarian well we get
into the issue so
what is the political angle i can't look
the moral angle we can
simply maybe simplistically say they're
just bad people which i think is fairly
true at this point but the political
angle is like what are you doing so i
keep coming back to this is why are we
doing it this way you are going to get
killed in the midterms you're going to
get killed in the election if there are
images of mass groups of americans
getting executed god forbid i'm not
going to knock on wood like joe biden my
god
he did that in his interview with george
stephanopoulos did you knock down wood
yeah no when uh stephanopoulos was like
is cause was this the best way to do it
he's like look you know it's it's
working out and stephanopoulos said
there's a lot of pandemonium and the
president i'm not making the same stuff
but look nobody died and then he
continued i was like oh god you're
actually knocking on wood literally
doing it you want to know so politically
you want to know why are they doing this
there's no upside to what they're doing
there's no rhyme or reason unless chaos
is the answer because biden is
is incompetent
he is well past his his his abilities to
do this in his age and the people around
him are just sitting there waiting to to
scoop up the scraps
it's it's it's it's almost like there's
no one there to actually support
administration it's
that's why i say trump got anti-elected
because this is not an administration
they're not stepping up and saying buddy
let me take care of this let me try and
fix some of this they're just sitting
there i'd imagine kamala harris is
sitting behind the curtain with it with
a grin like oh it's almost my time this
is exactly what i was hoping for you
want to know out of everybody who's
actually doing stuff for the people in
afghanistan this surprised the hell out
of me well glenn beckham here glenn beck
check out the story from the blaze glenn
back
travels to the middle east shares
updates from afghanistan rescue efforts
and photos featuring scores of afghan
christians boarding private planes glenn
beck
is an extremely wealthy man
he has absolutely no reason he doesn't
need to do this to prove anything to
anybody he's not going to he's not going
to bolster his he's rich already and
successful with a massive brand and a
massive company and he's doing this
because in my opinion he means it and
he's doing something good because he can
that to me is incredible
some other people there's a lot of
organizations that are fighting for this
as well that are trying to get people
out we saw that one one individual i
think his name was matt zeller was that
his name yeah he meant hillary he
appeared on msnbc talking about how
they've been warning the bite
administration as a former foreigner
that's right about our allies who need
our help i could not imagine you know uh
being somebody
uh who served over there who met a lot
of good people who risked their necks to
help you secure secure the city you know
stop terror attacks and then when you
leave
our government says oh that guy you knew
and worked with for a few years your
buddy we're going to leave him to die
but to but not to rehash all that we got
this story about glenn back this is
really incredible
the blaze reports in the blaze is glenn
beck's outlet
conservative fire brand glenn beck and
the nazarene fund's incredible efforts
in rescuing afghan christian refugees
are paying off and back and the nazarene
fund together have been able to free
scores and scores of people from
war-torn afghanistan absolutely amazing
at the time of this reporting the
nazarene fund has raised more than 30
million dollars to aid in the rescue of
afghan refugees in the early in an early
wednesday morning instagram update back
wrote i cannot specify for international
relations and security reasons exactly
where i am today but i am in the middle
east at the home base of operations for
the nazarene fund i will try to join
radio podcast right at the top of 9 a.m
on the blaze so i'm i'm not sure he's
actually in uh in afghanistan himself he
might he may be at like the ingestion
center which could be only a few hundred
miles away just over a border or
something maybe uzbekistan
he hasn't said where but regardless for
him to go and do this i think is
absolutely incredible and uh the people
who are able to do it is absolutely
amazing they say late tuesday night beck
shared a video of himself in what
appeared to be a plane and what she said
just got a briefing a few minutes ago on
what's been happening today and what's
been going on overseas we are still
moving people at this point it's like
you're a christian you're a female judge
i don't care get on the plane from
afghanistan it is horrible horrible to
hear what we are now we are we are now
cutting our time short 72 hours why is
the u.s now making a bad situation much
much worse by having them cut our
deadline why am i sitting here praising
glenn beck
for for flying in on his own dime to
rescue people i don't get it i really
really don't get it
why is he doing the job at the state
department and the department of defense
why did they abandon their helicopters
why did the u.s abandon air equipment i
know it seems like a it seems like it
was intentional man i can't i i look
look
i always try to give the benefit out i
always say i want to make the least
amount of assumptions but how could it
possibly be that they're for one
screwing up they didn't evacuate
americans or allies they abandoned an
air force base in the dead of night and
didn't tell the afghan security forces
how is that an accident i don't know
again i was saying i don't want to jump
on that i don't want to do that no the
resistance thing jump on impeachment
every time i know there have to be
hearings on this i need to know we all
need to know what happened and i just
want to clarify real quick when i'm
saying though
glenn beck's doing the job of the state
department and the department of defense
actual soldiers actual marines actual
state department officials and cia have
been doing everything they can i'm
talking about leadership is what i'm
dumping on right now i don't wanna i'm
not speaking ill of the rank and file
who are actually out there risking their
lives clearly as we saw today
i i'm you know what you know what has
always bothered me i i remember during
the bush era
when i was like a teenager we were
always complaining about war
didn't understand what the point of
being in these countries was but i we
always agreed on one thing not everybody
we don't blame the troops no we respect
them because they're the ones who stood
up and said you know we're here to serve
the country in good faith we were angry
with the establishment machine the
neocons the big the military-industrial
complex complex sending our brothers and
sisters men and women in uniform our
children
into harm's way
and for what and so right now it is the
worst of the worst example of this
13 u.s servicemen and women are dead
because
for one the nation building and two
when they were exiting the country they
just did not care
or or i'll tell you this
you know what
the people who voted for joe biden you
chose this
you you chose to have an emperor with no
clothes
i'm going to shout it out to sam harris
you guys probably know sam harris he is
a very prominent podcaster
and of course he was uh always very
anti-trump and during the election he
was always ragging on trump very much so
he tweet he quote tweeted himself in an
old tweet he said feeling overwhelming
gratitude for the adults in the room on
january 20th today he quoted that and
said publicly eating these words
syllable by syllable good that's so
that's that's that's how could he have
not have seen that see that sam harris
man to that point
you say biden voters voted for this the
thing that
anyone could have seen this coming biden
has been in congress since 1973 he has a
track record he's known this is like
when donald trump became president and
people especially the people like the
liberals who boosted him over marco
rubio during the primaries they're like
oh my god how could he be like this is
donald trump he has been like this since
he's been in the public eye none of this
is new this is who he has always been
this is his whole persona
biden is a known entity if you did not
know that he is one of the worst people
on foreign policy who's been wrong about
every major foreign policy issue since
the 1970s
that's on you you was on you to do your
research to listen but to your point
about being unelected
uh uh trump trump
anti-elected that's the thing i actually
i can't remember it was a guess on your
own show who was talking about this but
one of the things that the press did in
a quick sidebar i will say one thing
that's really impressed me uh
as much as anything about afghanistan
has oppressed me the press coverage has
actually been really good it's been
thorough it's been damning it's been uh
completely just straightforward they
love war
you know what i mean so the one time
you're getting an honest approach is
when biden screws up the war they want
i i don't know if clara's awarded like
cnn loves war no no no it's just the
editors itself editors they choose what
what's going to get the money what's
going to get attention and so right now
this is there's ratings but we heard the
with the veritas leaks we know what cnn
is all about but but i agree i do i do
the point i cannot remember his name he
was a guest on your show he was talking
about one of the things the media and
the democrats democrats did is they
terrified people every single day
everything trump did was new it was
unprecedented we've never seen anything
like this before this is the worst thing
that every single day even normal stuff
like dumping fish food in a koi pond in
japan and it was edited it was a fake
video it was a fake video i know i even
this is one of those moments you write
about is like what am i writing about
because they made oh my god you know
what happened in japan
every single day they terrified people
into voting for anything that was orange
man i i like to use the plumber analogy
but i think at this point we should use
the mechanic analogy i'd like you to to
imagine that your car breaks down and
you have two mechanics before you and
one guy is this tall loudmouth orange
guy going it's a disgusting horse car
it's nasty i hate it but i'll fix it
i'll make it run your car will be great
and you're like oh geez and then you
look over another guy and he's asleep
and when you're like yo are you gonna
fix my car he goes turn it on a shot of
the pressure and you're like i'm gonna
go with that guy who just said something
random some random gibberish sentence i
don't even know what he said and i'm
gonna trust it and then you get in your
car you're driving on the street and
then you're coming to a red light and
you press the break down and nothing
happens and you're like what's happening
i'm so surprised that i chose the guy
who couldn't even speak and now my car
crashes and but that's the thing is it's
not even who he was in 2020 there's 40
years of history to look at people i
know so many people who voted for him
over trump because they said i voted for
character competence and decency and
like biden is neither of those and he's
shown that repeatedly and i would say
too the the issue of people being
terrified every single day because
everything was unprecedented the irony
of that now is the united states gearing
up to abandon u.s citizens in a taliban
around country that actually is as
terrifying as all the bs most of the bs
they said about donald trump for all
years he was president so we come to
this area now and it's like where are we
supposed to go so you say bye no oh yeah
the the guy who's clearly not who he was
in 2012 that's what i can say about him
i covered him in 2012. i covered him in
2020 and i can tell you right now biden
is not the man he was in 2012 when he
filled paul ryan during the vice
presidential debate but even beyond that
one of the greatest tricks in american
politics is that joe biden rebranded as
his kindly old ice cream-eating uncle
when he's been one of the meanest knife
fighters in the senate he was famous for
it and for some reason people who've
been covering congress and the united
states and u.s politics for much longer
than i ever have just went along with it
old grandpa joe loves his grandpa and
his pawn scranton and i was like what
we all know who he is we've seen this
over and over again he is a ruthless
cunning
self-serving money-grubbing plagiarist
oh yeah i mean he made it over and over
again
a story about his own wife and daughter
dying who does that yeah he claimed the
man
he claimed the man in was a at fault and
drunk none of that was true he's a
sociopath he's a bad person and i know
people in 2020 after 40 years
40 years of facts and details in history
going i voted for character where what
character
trump was a character trump had a lot
man has too much character yeah that's
right and and you know all the things
they would say about trump it's like the
big problem is listen man to all the
trump haters i'm like i hear you i'm a
lot of it but bro when you come to me
like i would sit down with someone like
why do you dislike trump
seven out of the ten things they said
were fake news
did you see what happened with shinzo
abe when he's like just dumping he's
making us look bad i'm like oh you mean
when he did what shinzo did first like
shinzo dumped the food in so trump said
okay and then followed suit you're
blaming him for that well he's meeting
with with dictators and i'm like
negotiating peace deals with dictators
is a bad thing now obama did it
it was the casters
which i didn't care for i'm not saying
that's necessarily good but the idea is
that this is unprecedented we've never
seen this before in the history of like
woodpeckers they'll always negotiate
first i mean you can very fine people
betray your allies worst case scenario
you know the very fine people hoax joe
biden used to launch his campaign yeah a
lie i did for 2017 i did a database of
all the bogus and sloppy and just flat
out false reporting of the trump
administration and it ended up being
about a 13-page document if you printed
out and i stopped after 2017 because it
was too much work
there was so much nonsense to the point
and even now people are continuing
somewhere but i drawing a blank on his
name he's just he's this presidential
historian who works for nbc is still
railing against melania trump's uh
renovation of the rose garden talking
about how she made it into some weird
sort of fascist icon or she just
returned to the 1962 kennedy blueprint
and he's like he's she's destroyed what
jacqueline kennedy
remember when cnn reported that trump's
salt and pepper shaker was larger than
everyone else's how are these stories
and it wasn't even necessarily trump's
pepper shaker it was like in front of
him to the right was like two larger
square shakers and then to his left was
like smaller ones and they're like look
it's bigger it's like i'm sure
everyone's you trump doesn't have like
his own he pulls out of his coat he's
like it's fine i remember once looking
up and cnn had a chiron and it said
trump gets two scoops of ice yes and i
was like go turn cartoons on literally
anything else what am i doing to be fair
though that woman does these that no she
her whole gag is that she does goofy
funny recording story but the problem is
that all of cnn started to look like all
of her no no no they all of cnn picked
up the story and then i ended up seeing
i can't i don't know which show it was
but they were like two scoops of ice
cream and then they ran the story
i'm willing to bet jeff sucker was like
hey that actually plays well can you
re-roll it like in the next show you
know you know what jeff sucker he was he
was uh he is he out at cnn he's still
there right he's still there do you know
so for those that aren't familiar he's
the president i believe right president
of cnn yes oh i'm getting hazing as
chief something rather what was his job
before cnn nbc and what did he produce
at nbc apprentice
that's which is hey donald trump uh
tv
show i've written about this jeff
zucker's stewardship of cnn has turned
cnn cnn has wwe ified the news it's all
about heels and faces you've got the
good guys and the bad guys and tonight
don lemon's going to take on parents who
love their children and don't want him
to be masked like last night he was like
just because you have kids doesn't mean
you should have them yeah i said it like
this isn't new what just because you
have kids
yeah i'm not making this up by the way
he was railing again he should take your
kids from you he was railing against
parents who were anti-having their kids
masked for eight hours a day in school
and his big the big line that people
immediate wrote about and stuff was just
because you have kids doesn't mean you
should
period yeah i said it wow like what this
isn't even analysis you just
i can't even say the word you're just
what is this this is this is like w e f
w
that's not fair though to wwe because
wwe is over the top fun
also as i've written before wwe also has
the courage to admit what it is and
doesn't pretend to be anything else but
when i watch this clip recently i don't
know when it's from i don't watch watch
it but it was john cena's birthday or
something and he you know this clip he
like walks out and everyone's like
pointing and he's like he looks over
there's a present and he opens it and
it's a folding chair
like it's funny it's funny
it's also fake this yeah right but
that's the thing that we is fake yeah
hold on it's supposed to be i don't i
don't like the word fake when talking
about wrestling because it's
entertaining it's fiction
it's fiction cnn is not supposed to be
fiction right but that's the thing they
have the same approach which is heels
and faces there's good and see since
donald trump left office their ratings
have tanked it's been across the board
people don't know what to talk about
that's why
you find the next they've been focusing
on tucker carlson and fox news the fox
news has to be the new trump because
trump's right office they've tried i
love it uh brian stelter is like
what what he keeps trying to pin it on
someone else's is tucker carlson the new
trump
and then who else did he accuse is uh
they went after marjorie taylor green it
didn't stick they were talking carlson
it doesn't stick yeah they found a new
person who seems like every everybody
they try to accuse someone else of being
the new trump because they're they are
desperate to find a trump right there's
only one stone called steve austin
though yeah so you just can't replace
him and that's you see this in the news
you see this in msnbc honestly
if you told me in 2016 that msnbc would
be the slightly more reputable network
than cnn during the trump era i would
have said you're crazy
but i have to say it msnbc actually was
more reputable for all those years oh i
mean but all this kind of seems almost
beside the point but this goes to we
have the president who we have now
because people were told they needed to
be terrified of the other guy because
the stuff he did was dangerous and gonna
get everyone killed and the irony now is
we're looking at a situation where a lot
of people
god forbid you know just keep praying
that doesn't happen in afghanistan and
this is what we're at and i i find
myself look i don't blame biden voters
there is a part of me though that is
largely angry because biden is such a
known entity if you did not know this is
who he is that's on you you had 40 years
of material to look over there there's a
a few ways i approach this so so for one
you know i talked about the other day
that when it comes to fascist policies i
blame those who uphold them so with like
the new york city mandates
who's making the mandate and who's
enforcing it it's the mom and pop shops
that are enforcing it because the cops
can't go to every single restaurant no
it's only because the citizens of new
york are willing to do it uh who who's
who's the one who's confiscating
people's weapons and their right to
keeping their arms the police who are
doing it
however
with the american voter
i don't necessarily blame every person
who voted for bitem for for biden now
it's true that if you voted for biden
you voted for this
but the media who is manipulating and
lying and and ripping off the american
people deserve a massive amount of the
blame for this at the end of the day i
think it's the responsibility of the
individual to be informed and if you're
just watching cnn and believing it
without doing any fact checking yeah you
bear responsibility but how do you deal
with cnn msnbc and their outright lies
over and over again look man never been
a big fan of fox news i'm not a big fan
of a lot of their hosts but their news
like brett baer is great
bill hammer's great yeah
it's hard to find you know i
i have this thing on my instagram from a
couple years ago
i call it the i think we call it the cnn
challenge and what you do is you turn on
you turn on uh fox news
and uh and then see what they're
reporting and then see turn up and then
switch to cnn and see if they're
reporting on substantive world news
and so the the challenge is when you put
on cnn what are you put on fox news what
would i get so i'm like oh there's
protests in iran
a week later it's it's a hurricane a
large storm is coming to the u.s you
know
be prepared get supplies and i'm like
okay let's see what's on cnn and what
was it a panel talking about trump
every single time and project veritas
did had that expose where you had a guy
who said we don't we don't report
anymore
cnn used to go out and go on the ground
now it's like we all just sit around
because they're doing trump panels all
day i should say i should clarify that a
lot of my criticism is for cnn's
primetime
u.s news reporting there are a lot of
people on the digital side who do a lot
of great reporting especially especially
international porn and cnn international
itself is almost like its own entity
yeah completely devoid of zucker's over
oversight but you turn on like anything
between noon to 10 p.m and it's just
it's again it's like watching
professional wrestling but with suits
and ties you might as well just be
watching like a video of chickens
clucking it's like you're gonna be an
insult to chickens at least they're
doing good honest work that's true it's
true you know they're feeding families
that's true but i just mean to say that
you're not going to get any information
no in fact i'm sorry i'm sorry that's
wrong because if you watch chickens
clucking you'll you'll understand
chicken clocks after a certain amount of
time be like wow that the rooster did
that call that must mean danger you turn
on cnn you get dumber
you get less informed you get
misinformed and then they blame everyone
else for their problems
now you end up with people who live in
this
matrix dimension
the problem look i don't mind the press
that's opinionated i've long time said
the idea of an impartial press is kind
of a bs idea
really sort of popularized in like the
early 19th century the idea that you
know you use minimal words and all that
was a lot of it's about saving ink and
paper
i don't mind if you have an opinion or a
slant just be honest with me and if you
have a slant or an opinion just be fair
in your coverage if look if we had a
press being as tough and as
uncompromising on joe biden things might
have gone differently i'm not saying he
would have lost him no we had we had
collusion between big tech and the media
to to shut down news stories that made
hunt that made hunter biden and joe
biden look bad not just that but you
also had the president would disappear
for days on end in his basement and
people be like oh well he's probably
having some ice cream now what did
donald trump say today i'm like well
hold on as it turns out apparently
having a president whose entire campaign
strategy was to hide in his basement
wasn't great because they were seeing it
now in real time that's why i say trump
was anti-elected people when they when
people hit that biden button or or box
they weren't saying biden they were
saying no trump right
spite vote is such a powerful thing look
president former president barack obama
was a very exciting very likable very
charismatic candidate in his own right
but also a spite vote in 2008 was a who
was a direct answer to george w was so
unpopular at the time people weren't
necessarily voting against john mccain
they were voting against george w bush
who they were very unhappy with and it
helped that the democratic candidate was
extremely select and extremely easy to
want to vote for oh i mean i wasn't
covering politics at the time but even i
just casually watching the news knew
obama was going to win like you watch
that guy and be like yeah no i he's
going to be the next president oh yeah
yeah and then 2012
2012 mitt romney
mitt romney is such a difficult person
because he's such i think he's a decent
man a good man and a seasoned and
successful executive but he always
carried himself like he was embarrassed
to be a republican like he's always kind
of apologized he still is why
just i mean this is it's funny because
donald trump did to the nth degree what
i was screaming during 2012 was like own
it you're rich you're successful own it
and then donald trump was like okay okay
don't own it so hard because mitt romney
cares more about the opinion of the new
york times than he does about the
american people there's so many
republicans like that
they'll never like you why do you do
this they will never appreciate you
you're always going to be that that
weird kid on the playground that amuses
them but you're never going to be in the
clique yeah they will be like hey bite
this bite this worm in half eat this
pine cone it's so gross no no get out of
here get out of here weirdo yeah it was
you see this with uh cable news and and
even newspapers the the hallowed former
gop strategist who hasn't been a
republican or done anything conservative
for the last 30 years but they're
trotted out to say something bad about
republicans because you know blue on red
that's expected but red unread violence
ooh was dramatic this is great bring out
nicole wallace or john uh steve schmidt
steve schmidt oh adam kenzinger a
republican said
come on does anybody really
does
what they're doing with these like with
bill crystal and these neocons who are
now all of a sudden cheerleaders of the
democratic party jennifer rubin is one
of the one of the best right
she she starts
she she's the kind of conservative quote
unquote who comes out in his life and
says like i'm a principled conservative
and trump is bad and the democrats cheer
for it and then when trump when it comes
to like stacey abrams she's cheering for
stacey abrams then you get the lincoln
project they're like we gotta restore
the party of lincoln so we're anti-trump
then trump you know gets voted out and
they go
well trumpism is still the republican
party so where were the democrats i
guess yeah now you have them going on
being like well we're going to have to
save gavin newsom in california i'm like
what part of this is conservative steve
schmidt is marched out to this day on
msnbc regularly in the chiron it says
former gop strategist and he comes out
he's like the republican party there's
now the party of fascism
former gop strategist he hasn't done
anything successful since arnold
schwarzenegger was re-elected in 2006.
he's dining out on that credit for
almost as long as we've been in
afghanistan and yet they just pump him
out because this is this is what they
want these are the republicans that who
are republicans i i would not put mitt
romney in the same category with steve
schmidt but there's there's that weird
strain of like embarrassed
like oh i know my rank and file are loud
and they wear red hats and i'm sorry you
know i'm sorry people say rhino
republican and name only oh i remember
that one people say that yeah absolutely
all the time but you know who the real
rhinos are it's like thomas massey and
rand paul because they're the odd people
out the entirety of the republican party
is around doing nothing and then you get
a small handful of people who actually
stand up and if i gotta if i'm gonna
look at the majority of the republican
party as you know
on their best day as speed bump for
democrats and then i look at you know
marjorie taylor green lauren bobert uh
uh rand paul thomas massey who actually
stand up for stuff and holly and a few
others
i'm like they're
they're not the same as the republicans
arizona democratic senator uh christian
cinema is more reliable for what i want
she's the democrat oh and joe manchin
i'm like they're actually more aligned
with me than a lot of these other
supposed celebrity republicans who get
trotted out on cable news to go trump is
bad tucker
tucker called lindsey graham a leftist
oh lindsey graham
i mean right i don't i don't think i
have his harsher criticism when you were
saying rand paul was a rhino i was like
i think he would not want to be called
republican i think he still prefers
libertarian but he's in the republican
party so right i mean he's not
he's not his father i'll just leave it
the republican party
is the the group of weirdos in high
school
who wish they were in with the popular
kids
and the democrats are like obama is a
celebrity you know he's a rock star they
got the media
they love it republican the republicans
are suit wearing stodgy and unhip and
they're not with it so you get all these
republicans who are desperate to make
the new york times happy because they
want to be cool but they'll never be
cool nobody likes being hated but it
just kind of blows my mind that a lot of
these republicans forget you have like
50 of the country if not more behind you
you don't have to win over that other
half that despises you not for long
don't well we'll see about that
this you know i always come back to this
the idea that i know it's always going
to slip away and we just can't win and
all that stuff i like and maybe it's too
simplistic but if you can't sell and
package liberty to voters then maybe
you're just a bad salesman maybe the
problem is you we need better we i'm a
conservative i'm not a republican i
haven't been a registered republican for
a long time
uh conservatives need better
spokespeople
spokesmen and women let me be exact
about it and the idea that no it's just
not going to work we can't we can't win
we can't sell liberty why can't we sell
liberty they can certainly sell big
government how can we not package
something that's far more attractive let
me pull up these polls and we'll break
this down so we got this from civics
democratic party favorable rating 53
percent unfavorable 41 favorable for the
democratic party
republican party what do you think it's
going to be
probably worse
the republican party is 62 unfavorable
and 26 favorable and you know why that
is
let's go back to the democrats real
quick okay how do democratic voters feel
about the democratic party 86 percent
favorable 7 unfavorable how do
republicans feel about the democratic
party
95 percent unfavorable
how about independent voters independent
voters say 63 unfavorable 26 26
favorable okay so the democrats
overwhelmingly like the democratic party
republicans overwhelmingly dislike it
and independent voters lean towards not
liking it
let's take a look at republican voters
and how they feel about the republican
party
they're
65 percent favorable a 20 percent drop
from democrats in their own party
republican voters don't like their own
party
that's a 30 drop right 95 to 16. no no
it was uh democrats were 85 favorable
look i'll give democrats this and they
they stick together they do they have
great um what's the word i'm looking for
discipline when it comes to sticking
together that's part of the reason why
people like alexandria ocasio-cortez
stick out because they don't march the
party line which is different
but the fact that republicans don't like
their own party i think that might
contribute to the fact that the
republican party has been feckless for
years that it seems embarrassing of
itself but i also suspect a large part
of it might have to do with the fact
that conservative voters tend to be
highly individualistic and they're not
beholden to a tribe or that sort of
loyalty might see from the team that
believes in sort of like the collective
like the board floating through space
not to say democrats are the borg i have
they are i love the democrats the
democrats are
god's awesome what's the old reagan
quotes not that they're wrong it's just
they know so much that isn't true yeah
but uh you know so i'm not surprised i
think even enduring good well yeah even
during good years i think you would
still find high unfavorability with
republicans because i think part of
being a conservative
is not
being part of a tribe or beholden to it
so if you've got some qualms with it
you're going to say it and now i don't
want to simplify it and be like ah
republican party's fine republicans are
just like no republican parties clearly
god i think kevin mccarthy's way in and
over his head way the worst man for the
moment right now i think
97 percent of the republican party is
just
it's like it's the
dead air it's it's radio silence
they don't do anything look uh a really
great example
ilhan omar does what you know i refer to
as crop dusting anti-semitism what what
the democrats do they circle the wagons
and they say we're not going to condemn
her we'll condemn hate right
what do they do to marjorie taylor green
they stripped her over committee because
she said stuff before she got elected
yeah the republicans are sitting there
as the losers and and the bully
democrats are like you want to be with
the cool kids well then you got to go
pick on that weirdo and they go whatever
you say democrats and then they start
look are we cool yet we're we're
insulting our our own our own friends
yeah no like you even get in the area of
i i i'm not even trying to litigate what
she said whether it was right or wrong
but the fact that republicans didn't say
look i don't agree with it but don't you
dare because we'll come for your
anti-semites and that's the thing too
what do you think well that's the thing
too what margaret green taylor said you
can make very clear argument that was
offensive
but the stuff that comes out of ill
omaha ill on omar's mouth and rashida
talib is straight up anti-semitic i mean
straight up the idea that american jews
are pro-israel because of the money i
call i'm sorry what did you just say and
the democrats the the dual loyalty the
dual loyalties you can't trust those
jews you know and then where the
democrats do they go okay we'll pass a
resolution saying all lives matter
that's what they did and then the
democrats were like that did the trick
anyway i'm back to work no
in the republican that's why trump won
because because people finally saw a
fighter who was gonna be like i'll fight
for you i oh look i'll out myself on
this i did not vote for him in either
election i did not like trump he's not
my he's not my ideal president i i want
to john i want john adams for president
is what i want uh yeah but he's been
he's he's dead isn't he yeah he died
yeah he died oh god no are you serious
he died in like 18 18. i don't think
trump i hate i hate to use the word
really i hate to use the word that's sad
i hate to use the word because it's so
overused by the press and and
was concerned trolling republicans but
trump did not have the temperament for
the most important job in the world not
the country
i did not like his opponents so i
certainly didn't vote for them either
but i just joe jorgensen uh
for who i always vote when i do write in
this mickey mouse
um i almost voted for my wrote myself
um but my point that i'm trying to get
at after you know telling everyone my
dirty secret is that actually my dirty
secret oh god my dirty secret in 2016 as
i vote for evan mcmullan who's that
i'm so sorry everyone
he had one job which was
don't embarrass me and he couldn't even
manage that guy couldn't even manage a
cup of coffee the most embarra it was
just a protest vote i know he wasn't
going to win i didn't particularly care
for the guy i was trying to register my
protest that neither one of these
candidates deserves my vote because i
don't think either one of them deserves
the office now what i can say is the
trump presidency was way better than i
thought it was going to be
i think we
we being conservatives benefited from
the fact that he did surround himself
with a lot of good people
he was actually great for pro-life
issues he was great on foreign policy
the fact that you get uh bahrain the uae
and israel sitting together signing a
treaty
that's amazing moving the embassy this
is great presidents have just doing been
doing lip service for years he actually
did it i'm deeply impressed getting
prisoners back from north korea i'm like
all right credit where it's due
the thing though
is that
even having him you know
i think i would prefer him right now to
the thing that's already in office yeah
i can't lie no like i didn't vote for
the guy but i think i would prefer that
because what's happening now i don't
think would have happened under trump's
watch wouldn't it happen under kamala
harris either this biden's gone man he's
like got like two days he can see like
two days ahead
he slurs his words he's misspeaks words
in his national addresses he trails off
he's not a military guy never he never
was and now he's like a direct or like a
demented it seems like he's like
you know edging towards dementia or if
it's not and he's in he's in military
man
is that
is that the answer to our question the
why which is that an incompetent man is
in charge and he's completely surrounded
by yes man not a single person mark
milley wouldn't wouldn't take the risk
because he doesn't want his career to
get trashed a month before he retires
it's as simple as that that's what
that's why what's happening is happening
one of the symptoms of dementia is
outbursts of rage yeah because people
who are losing their mind get frustrated
because they they're desperately trying
to hold on and so like imagine you're
having a conversation and in your mind
you're thinking like i would like to
talk about you know my dog fido and then
you're talking and all of a sudden your
mind goes blank and you get angry now
you get it so they then so you look at
some of these things where biden has
snapped on reporters remember when he
went to that guy and he was he started
yelling at him over and over yeah
he's done things like that a lot
it's because he gets asked a question
and he and he's like
yes it's like you mentioned you know
back in 2012 how he you know he tore up
uh uh paul ryan and now imagine
being that guy who's who's winning
winning these elections for decades and
now you're sitting you're unable to
speak at the podium you're going to get
you're going to get frustrated and angry
i only think i would say maybe slight
pushback on that as it goes back to my
earlier statement about we have a track
record biden has been snapping on
reporters for decades that's actually
how he usually interacts with an
uncomfortable or unfriendly question
he's always been
an expletive that i won't say on the air
he has always been mean that's not new
this goes back he's a big meanie this
goes back to what i was saying earlier
the idea that he was able to rebrand
himself as his kindly old man and
everyone went along with him was like no
he he was famously mean
famously short with people famously uh
kurt
rude didn't uh and then he just
it was awesome
didn't mitt romney like strap a dog to
his car or something like that oh my
gosh yeah they went for do we want to
litigate this
they went for a long car ride the dog
had diarrhea so they put in the dog
carrier on top of the car and
uh her name was gail collins of the new
york times i want to say she wrote about
30 articles about 30 different columns
talking about that dog on the roof
amazing i mean i mean look i've never
owned a dog
where do you put a dog that has diarrhea
for a car ride in the carrier oh do you
put it on the car or in the back put it
in the car
it's a dog what do you do with a baby a
baby baby doesn't have fur
that's true too it was it a carrier it
was in the carrier but apparently
putting the carrier on top of the car is
very bad
i guess i guess would you not put a dog
on it i don't know i just thought of
that i thought it was a funny story oh
no it's we can litigate all of this
stuff well so where do we so right now
we've got uh we got this story from the
hill holly blackburn call for biden to
resign
there's been other insinuations that he
should be impeached if he's not if he
doesn't resign but then what do we do do
we do president kamala yeah yeah please
anything is better than this guy right
now it's military we he left thousands
of people behind
that's right
and they were and they said they didn't
want a black hawk down moment they
didn't want to send in this is like the
iranian hostage thing which was the big
it was a 52 people 52 and already 13
people have been killed times times a
hundred
like people didn't die no one died in
that that scandal that hostage scandal
that i know of they were rescued these
people died already right i sound like
jimmy dory he's [ __ ] jimmy i love you
these are these are us troops who were
there
knowing the risks or they were they were
officially affiliated with the troops
they weren't all troops right they were
military there are 13 dead u.s service
members servicemen on top no they're
marines and a navy medic corpsman and
then they're also civilian casualties
although i don't think we have the
numbers on the civilian casualties yet
bunch of afghanis
afghani by the way is the currency i
know people keep saying that when they
try to say the plural right afghan
plenty of civilian afghans i believe
died in the imagine uh serving on a ship
with with a captain who's you know
let's just call let's just call him
sporadic
and you're like i'm here to do my duty
and then the people who are on shore are
like hey we're going to put this crazy
old man up in there i i can't i can't
imagine what it must feel like for a lot
of these guys who are like i'm going to
do my best but they know deep down
they're in trouble because if bidens can
control your ship he fires at the enemy
ship and he misses and he
thinks about how to do it again he's got
people and then your ship gets hit with
the with the
artillery round and then all of a sudden
everyone realizes they're going to die
and that's what people don't understand
can happen in reality
if you're lazy with military they didn't
think about any of this
when look joe biden campaigned to be
president he said i want that job he
knew trump negotiated this deal to
withdraw biden said i want to be in
charge of the world's most powerful
military and a bunch of people said i
would like that man to have control of
the world's most powerful military and
to oversee our withdrawal from
afghanistan in the middle east
and this is what they voted for he's
been running for president since the
late
1980s been playing wanting this by the
way i mean him being president the way
he is is like you ever see that old
twilight zone episode where the guy is
finally alone to read all the books he
wants but he breaks his glasses you
spend your entire life
most of your entire life you spend a lot
of your life trying to be president and
you finally get it and it turns out you
were too incompetent to even execute the
basic duties of your office it was time
now it was my time it's not fair hey
this is not fair oh my god man you know
i'm a president here's the deal but so
like to your point if it's just sheer
incompetence maybe kamala could could
take up but that's
this is status gospel he's not going to
get impeached he's not going to resign
unless he's not fit for command though
you've got to relieve him of command i
think you'll have 25 minutes you'll have
to drag him from the oval office with
his teeth markers still he doesn't want
it 25th amendment kamala harris what if
she comes out because 20th amendment
requires the vice president to come out
and say the president is not competent
and then pelosi set up that panel they
were expecting this
i don't know look i you were saying
earlier that you know behind the curtain
comm was like that is my time
i don't know have you seen her recently
in some of her public appearances she's
got a i don't want to be here right she
looks shaken i mean not just shaking but
like she sees what's happening and do
you think she wants to be in charge of
this the clean up after this would you
want it i wouldn't want it i would do it
but i mean i wanted it i would take it
if it was there and i had to have it
that's what i'm saying that's what i'm
saying is she going to you know work
behind the scenes to take this and i
want to clean this up here's here's the
difference
you ian you and kamala both don't want
it you don't want it because you don't
want to be in charge you don't want to
control have the power but you're
willing to accept responsibility to do
the right thing to fix the mess kamala
doesn't want it because she doesn't want
to deal with the mess she just wants the
power you see how that works
do you want the title
commonly called the front line harris
doesn't want to deal with the crisis she
just wants the power then she's not fit
for command either exactly but we keep
saying not fit for command it extends
beyond biden maybe biden is an f up who
doesn't understand foreign policy as
he's shown for the last several decades
but the generals this is literally their
job is knowing this stuff who signed off
on all this who okay who didn't push
back i mean millie didn't push back do
it miller can't be the only one who else
so many how many they have does there
need to be a clear house they were too
busy dealing with white rage you know i
want to understand you want to hear
about white rage i got some white rage
right now over this yeah i'll write
general milly about this
it's i don't know where it goes from
here i don't know it doesn't end well
who's responsible for this who makes the
call of where the money goes ron paul
he's such
such a funny character he's the one you
know he's one of those guys that
before
you know when i first started covering
politics i was like this seems like a
goofy little man
and then
repeatedly he was like oh he was right
about that yeah it'd be like and be like
well i didn't i didn't doubt him i'm
like oh i did i mean the one the one big
one i'm sorry i know this is a total
tangent was out of the fed and i was
like this is silly and then the fed's
like you absolutely will not out at us
i'm like okay
why not yeah okay
you've seen casino remember when sharon
stone asks her husband robert de niro
for money because she wants to go see
her pimp boyfriend and she doesn't want
to tell her husband that but she asked
for like fifteen thousand dollars and
he's like what for and then she makes a
big stink she's like i shouldn't have to
tell you what he's like and then the
line and i'm always reminded with this
stuff he's like well i wasn't i wasn't
interested but now i am yeah that's how
i feel with a lot of stuff that ron paul
has talked about like i didn't really
have a strong opinion on this but the
fact that you guys are so reluctant to
do this now
i gotta be honest you know i'd take a
president ian right now
i'll take a president tim
for sure yeah i don't want to be
president but i want to be vice
president military strategy that's just
the top of the game right i just want to
be vice president i just travel the
world shake hands try new food be great
we'd be we'd be better off with like
you know uh rick smith from dubuque iowa
who's like a local plumber as president
it's the old buckley's saying is that
you'd be better off being ruled by three
random names from the phone book than
most of these eggheads and that's
people can you think you can do this
better like yes me and three completely
random people could probably do what's
happening in afghanistan better i know
enough that you'd get the civilians out
first like this isn't hard
not only that but uh some of the
low-ranking guys in afghanistan could
have done a better job and i imagine
that's going to be really frustrating to
be deployed on the ground knowing and
sitting there being like why are they
doing this they're understaffed and
they're under resourced over there
they're working with what they have
which is not great and the other thing
too i don't think a lot of people have
been talking about this sort of
psychological angle to this the guys who
are there now know that they're working
on the final chapter to a big foreign
policy failure they know everything
they're doing has been a build up to
failure and they've been tasked now with
trying to get the last americans out
while surrounded by the taliban can you
imagine what that job is even like and
then losing at least 13 of your
colleagues all in the same day i mean
this is none of this had to happen you
know i i this was all
uh this was all done
by a president and a white house that
doesn't know what it's doing or
some people have suggested it's actually
just malicious i've had those jobs man
where you're like my boss is dumb and
they don't know how this stuff works
there's a lot of jobs you'll get where
the manager is hired externally and so
they've never actually worked say the uh
the soda machine or the cash register
and they're sitting there trying to tell
you how it works and you're like dude
you have no idea what you're talking
about right it's frustrating i could not
imagine what it must be like to be
deployed in afghanistan
and knowing what's going on in the
country knowing how the people react
knowing what the taliban is and then
getting these orders where you're like
you want me to do what right because
this is your life on the line this ain't
a cheeseburger or a cash register i
can't imagine what the us marines feel
like seeing
afghans possible afghan allies uk
nationals people with their papers and
they can't take them or go out and
defend them because they've been ordered
to stay put the 82nd airborne has been
ordered not to go outside of kabul to
save americans and other people while
the british paratroopers are going in
and the french special forces i've been
going into these sort of daring night
raids all over and the americans just
have to sit there i can't imagine how
demoralizing how uh much of a shock that
must be this like as an american like
look as civilians
we know the idea that americans being
left behind is is such a this is i never
thought that this could happen i can't
imagine what this is like for guys
dedicated his life to being in the armed
services
would it be like to you can't go out and
get those americans i can't do that and
we might leave some behind
that that's gotta you know they talk a
lot during the trump year sorry not to
interrupt i talked a lot during the
trump years about unprecedented stuff
the idea that we are on course to
abandon americans in a foreign country
to a terrorist death cult
nothing like that has happened in this
country before you know what really
tears at me
i mean obviously the us troops and the
loss of life is the biggest thing but
i'm just thinking like
if they didn't abandon the afghan
security forces the way they did
afghanistan could have been successful
it could have been
they could in fact you know uh we've
talked with other vets on the show where
they said something like you draw down
you know the overall majority 90 plus
percent of american forces leave a few
commanders or you know strategy
logistics with some air support some
drones and it's it's done we we get out
that minimal support can help keep
things secure and then i look at what
happened with with evacuating the air
force bases in the middle of the night
not informing the afghan uh security
forces and i'm i wonder if
if biden did this properly would there
be a secure afghanistan right now for
their people
i mean maybe big problem that the u.s
military has also reported is that the
afghan
government is extremely corrupt and
susceptible to bribes and looking at
their way another problem that i know a
lot of military have reported is that
the afghans that they've tried to train
the training has been very difficult
because there's a lot of lack of
discipline um i've seen the videos man
can you do jumping jacks
it's called side saddle uh people
jumping jacks of people straight up
abandoning just walking away because
they don't want to hashish because they
don't want to do it anymore so i don't
know if afghan i'm sorry if afghanistan
would still be standing with just a few
things different i mean it's not like
for
it's not like there was a lack of
spending or a lack of arms or lack of
training so maybe would stay in maybe
would fall but
when they keep the white house keep
saying we plan for all contingencies
apparently afghanistan falling to the
taliban was not one of those
contingencies and how you overlooked
that despite everything you were being
told by your guys on the ground about
how difficult it is to train them and
how
corrupt the government is well known
corrupt everyone knew that
we all know that we don't work in
government we don't work in the united
states military we know it's corrupt
it's interesting i always wondered like
what
why is bribery so less common here you
know
i don't think it is no i don't know it
is it's
bribery's common but it's much less
common like i i hear these stories oh
look when you get pulled over
would you say to the officer how much to
no i say make the ticket go away of
course not never going to happen but in
russia in russia and south america too
in peru i was going to say in costa rica
i i was in costa rica once i was warned
the cops will try to shake you down for
uh
for a bribe so okay yeah to that point
that's what you mean it's substantially
more common in so many other countries
and i wonder why that is
uh maybe we have more watchdogs more
robust
scruples like rule of law fear like i
can't do that that's just wrong or i
could get in trouble
you know we we know the cops gonna
arrest you for it there's most likely
yeah yeah but in these other countries
the cops expect it
i don't know i mean i think maybe just a
lack of of robust law system lack of uh
respect for law i'm not trying to get
all you know blue lives matter or
whatever but like this is very sort of
strong culture in america you know
you pull over your respect
you have that interaction i have never
once been tempted to slide a cop a 50
bill or anything yeah it's weird i think
that would end very poorly for me yeah
yeah that would probably just be like
i would imagine it's felony right yeah
yeah you can private cop i i believe
rule of law man that's a big big part of
the foundation of this this whole
project of the united states it's it's
sad when people
do things that especially people in
power do things that are illegal and and
don't get reprimanded for it like the
president's son
yeah and like hillary clinton with
emails like that was viciously illegal
what she did she skirted all foia laws
i'm not all into like punishing everyone
for every crime all the time like i
definitely like leniency and like these
people on january 6th should be released
that should all be pardoned that's
we need unity right now
um
but i mean at some point you've got to
this is law and order you know why you
get january 6 because of hillary clinton
getting away yes yes
i mean i don't
i don't know if the two are generally
generally connected but i will say one
thing that's really demoralizing and it
easy to give into anger is the
expectation that people like hunter and
hillary will never see justice and they
break laws that anyone else would go
away for this is what i mean when people
feel demoralized like there's nothing
they can do to actually get justice
we're living under an arco tyranny they
just they
what do you what do you what do you do
when you back an animal into a corner
it's gonna fight you get a rabbit
rabbits like to run right but you put it
into a you know one dimensional uh
a burrow for instance they have no
there's nowhere to go they fight
and so that's why when people get
desperate they do desperate things going
back to our earlier conversation about
desperation that's why i i i agree with
you on the pardoning of of these people
outright because as much as people might
not want to do it it you need to be like
okay we're gonna we're gonna call time
out on this one we're gonna say guys
please don't do this
we're gonna let these guys go
john hancock did that after shae's
rebellion we've talked a little bit
about it right after the articles of
confederation were signed big you know i
don't know do you know much about the
farmers rebellion that caused them
basically they had to centralize command
of taxes because the states were taxing
the farmers the farmers didn't have the
money to pay so they revolted
uh john hancock pardoned those guys i
think two people ended up getting put to
death for the rebellion but he pardoned
like everybody that was involved and i
don't know because of that we have a
country today if he persecuted those
people we probably wouldn't have
i don't know and i hadn't actually
thought about it i have been troubled by
the fact that some people are still
being kind of held indefinitely it's
terrible that is so
pointless and terrifying maybe the word
trouble is a little too much of a under
reaction uh the fact that people are
still being held is not right i mean
charge them charge them send them a
court date at least but this this
indefinite detention thing
i don't think that's the right response
i don't know about pardoning though i
haven't quite thought about that i mean
a lot of
vandalism at least at the very least is
a crime right you could say if you
pardon them that they might do it again
that argument could be like hey we're
not gonna but i mean if you do it a
second time you're going away buddy
don't don't trespass on on federal
property learn your lesson but they
weren't there to hurt people
well i mean i think a lot of the
security forces there that they would
would beg to differ i guess that's a
good point it's contention some people
think they were there to hurt people
some people don't i see it as that they
were there protesting out of rage but i
didn't see any like overt i mean there
was like but there was like the sticks
and the beatings and all that stuff you
can see the footage of that there's
enough to say there's a mindless crowd
of a lot of different wants eighteen men
were convicted and sentenced to death
and shay's rebellion
18. out of 4 000. and he pardoned the
rest uh most were granted amnesty for
signing
they signed confessions acknowledging
participation uh several hundred were
indicted on charges but most most were
pardoned and 18 were convicted and
sentenced to death
i i i gotta read more about this this
whole process because i know john
hancock actually stepped down before
while that before that rebellion he was
like i'm not getting involved and then
the rebellion happened and the
interesting thing is it's not shay's
like apostrophe s it's shay's his name
his name is s-h-a-y-s
it was the shay's rebellion not shea's
rebellion interesting yeah
he was uh yeah he fought in the
revolutionary war
and then because of
came back from the war they didn't pay
the troops in the revolutionary so all
these farmers came back from the war
with no money and then they found out
that they owed all this money
in taxes because their farm had been
accruing all this debt while they were
gone they didn't have the money paid for
it so they made them debtor slaves
they'd put them in prison and the
farmers had enough they would go to the
courthouses and this and that famous
letter from thomas jefferson about the
tree of liberty comes from shae's
rebellion
no but at the very least for the the
capital rioters
i'm i'm still stuck on the the sort of
prefer term insurrectionist because i'm
not sure if that's
explicitly um accurate but at the very
least assaulting a police officer is a
crime a lot of officers were assaulted
that day i i know the one was not beaten
to death with a fire extinguisher they
were i'm still kind of amazed at the
amount of um false information that came
out which i mean i guess i'm not amazed
because when you have chaotic events you
get a lot of conflicting reports
officer siknik according to the dc
medical examiner did not succumb to any
injuries internal or external suffered
that day but there is ample footage of
people
beating police officers shoving them the
guy you know getting crushed in the door
maybe you could pardon all the
trespassing charges and then just if
people were violent bust them for that
if they broke windows bust them for that
you can see there were a lot there was
lots of damage done to the capitol
building the one thing
i mean it's such a it's a tricky issue
for me to discuss because a lot of the
legal ramifications and legal legalese
that's involved in it
uh but one thing that has always struck
me i was watching it i used to when i
was living in dc um when it happened i
wasn't at the capitol i was a couple
blocks away where i lived and i lived in
capital east
um
i'm sorry hilly's whatever it's called
uh
one thing that struck me though is i
thought for sure watching that whole
unfold the crowds the nervousness the
screaming the breaking through doors the
shattering windows
i was convinced that i was about to see
live streamed uh kent state 2.0 oh wow i
am amazed you
ashley babbitt is dead rest in peace
again i'm not making any legal judgments
on her participation or anything i don't
like her when people get killed i don't
like death
um
i'm amazed that the one death that's
directly attributable um directly
connected to the violence that day
there's a there's one death i'm amazed
whoever trained those police officers
uh in you know violent response i think
she get an award because i thought for
sure there was going to be guns were
going to be drawn people were you know
because they were getting the cops were
letting them in what do you mean oh some
cops were not all of them though but
especially when you had like that one
part uh with the speaker's chamber that
goes in where babbitt jumped in i mean
they clearly were not letting him into
that that's where they were they were
pushing against each other right and
then you had the other doors where the
cops actually opened them up well
not the speaker's chamber you had two
guards two cops guarding it and then
they no i mean the building outside the
building yeah some doors were open not
all of them some of them were forcibly
open you can see the inside what i'm
saying is there was this push into like
one of the center doors and then you get
like the swat uh the cops with special
they're shoving people are getting
smashed inside the you know rotund or
whatever and then you had doors off to
the side
there's video of it right open them
right up some of them yeah and they're
like
disagree with it but you agree with your
right to protest yeah i saw that some
cops are taking selfies with them no
that's weird because i remember in the
aftermath of that there was a lot of
talk about how the cops were in on it
and i think that was ignoring that as a
as a riot mitigation efforts or ryan
mitigation tactics this is something you
can do we can kind of ferry people get
out of your system get out of the
building as opposed to you know you're
not going to know lord the ring stand
there with your shield and try to do a
battle to the death especially when
you're grossly outnumbered no yeah we i
don't know if we need to litigate all
this but i
i just keep thinking about the day and
the sort of chaos and confusion and i'm
still amazed that
there were not more like itchy trigger
fingers i think that's a huge blessing
and i'm amazed again i'm not trying to
mitigate babbitt's death or anything or
make any legal judgment on that
uh but i'm surprised that there was you
were one down you were there i wasn't
there i was not in the building i lived
near you were close by though
helicopters wow yeah and i'm just amazed
that it wasn't more violent now i know
whoever sees this would probably
say that your instruction wasn't violent
i'm not saying that well we now know i'm
surprised it didn't spiral more out of
control as what i'm saying is now
definitive it was not an insurrection as
much as we always we always think we
were always saying it wasn't the fd fbi
came out and said that there's no
evidence of coordination not from the
present or anybody else and of the
groups that actually plan on breaking
and they had no actual plans but does
that and see this is why i was saying
earlier that's difficult to discuss
because does that
i don't know if that negates the legal
term for uh um insurrection just because
no one's been charged with insurrection
just because there's no
just because there's no coordination
doesn't mean it's not an insurrection i
mean storming capital building during uh
congress business to certify the
election doesn't that not technically
count as insurrection ask with
prosecutors why they're not charging
anybody with insurrection then because
there's none
no it didn't happen
i guess but i was just saying i don't
know the fact that there was no
coordination i don't think that means
that it wasn't insurance i actually
think if there's no coordination there's
no insurrection yeah so like
if you how are you gonna the
insurrection is
the idea is like a direct it's intent
it's a goal it's it's you're doing a
thing for a reason it was a riot
yeah a lot of people who've been
interviewed since then who participated
almost to a man they're like i have no
idea why i did it i just got caught up
you know you i don't know if any of you
have been involved in sort of a um
spur-of-the-moment mass movement
activity with a group yeah
i've covered a bunch of riots oh
i was at mardi gras wall street that's a
good one mardi gras
turkey yeah but like but no no no i was
saying like uh the zakati park stuff
like a lot of that is just you get this
mentality like let's let's do it b
legends you don't really think about it
and you see we've seen this post
insurrection a lot of people have been
like i have no idea why i did it i just
we know some mentality male mentality
it's a strange real thing and why people
cheer at sports events yeah
why are you screaming
no i mean you can't disturb the the
opponent's team if you yell really loud
if you if someone scores like your team
scores a point you're gonna be like also
on a microcosm i was sitting at my
friend's baseball game and my friend hit
the ball and i went yeah really loud and
the first baseman got stunned when i
screamed and the ball went by
i was like i'm the fourth man so now you
can you can with the riot you can break
it down to was it insurrection or was it
just people got caught up and things got
out of control
i think
more of the latter is what it seems to
me the thing that i keep coming back to
is i'm just surprised it didn't spiral
more with the lack of communication half
the coffee people knocked out and just
like walking home some people walked out
and some people were hospitalized it's
like there was no communication half the
cops didn't know what was happening a
lot of about 140 police officers
suffered various injuries
and yet
like there wasn't shootings there
weren't people don't you move
i'm surprised that's all i'm saying i'm
just surprised i really thought
stuff was going to go sideways super
fast super oh yeah yeah and i'm excited
i heard that there wasn't i heard there
was tear gas in the rotunda i was like
oh man yeah wow it's getting hot like
you saw a facebook ban before that one
video of uh the one capital um capital
police officer who like redirected the
protesters away from the main i don't i
don't actually believe that
perhaps my point though in that video he
has his hand on his gun the whole time
like again i'm just saying the
everything there seemed to me to be
about one degree from going really bad
really fast and it did go really bad for
one person um
there was they pushed this narrative
that he guided the group away or
whatever and i'm like i don't believe
that was his intent i think he was just
backing away from an angry mob
i know yeah i mean i don't know if that
was his intent it's what he did though
so
even if you fall if you accident into
something successful no he he didn't
though it's it's he went up the stairs
and and went a specific direction in
fact you could argue he actually led
them to pelosi's office no i mean then
they broke in and then they stole their
laptop why don't we why don't we say
that
because
i'm sorry what why don't we say that cop
actually led them no he led them look
the cops opened the doors we know that
and then this one cop all of a sudden is
is guiding the protesters next thing we
know they're in pelosi's office stealing
her laptop
yeah i think no the point is the cop was
backing away from an angry mob he didn't
want to confront them and he chose a
direction to back away the cops should
also be pardoned for any involvement in
this the people didn't hurt people like
you said there wasn't violent there was
very very very little violence the
ashley baby thing's terrifying but she
was like forcing her away it looked like
into the inner chamber and you know they
were defending the capital um none of
these those people basically the cops
and the people kept it pretty civil
so i i think we should move on from this
my fear is that the patriot act you know
terror uh
investigators want to use this as an
example to like use their
tools of spying on the american people
the point they put the list together
after the communications of trump
supporters right but it's that's doesn't
make that's not the liberty angle right
now the liberty angle is to pardon this
mess and move on we have the afghan we
have people like
on their last legs in afghanistan right
now and we need a country a unified
imagine this imagine if joe biden came
out announced a formal pardon for all of
those involved in january 6th and then
all of the democrats would come out
supporting him being like you know we
agree this is the right thing to do
how would that how would how would that
manifest in the culture yeah people
would start shivering because they have
so much energy and they don't have
anywhere to direct it they'd have to
start meditating but i mean think about
it like loving each other if he did that
democrats would immediately support the
move saying this is this is leadership
unifying this country and then trump
supporters will be like that's a good
thing that he's doing yeah
i don't know if i don't know if
democrats would get behind it
they are admitted committed to this to
this investigation in this committee no
but it would be a heart it would be a
hard sell i mean he would have to sell
him on at first obviously he wouldn't
blindside him no i think if biden
blindsided them they would immediately
fall in line
he better do something if he wants to
save face right now he's got to do some
epic diplomacy
now it's interesting though watching
some again i i think a lot of the
international reporting on afghanistan
has been pretty sharp uh and very sort
of like uncompromising but it's been um
predictably disgusting watching how a
lot of commentators and you know cable
news talking heads
um i mentioned this because of january 6
specifically you have people like joy
reid
uh who've been trying to redirect
attention from afghanistan to the
january 6th being like we should talk
about the terrorists at home yeah our
taliban he's like well first of all we
can walk and chew gum at the same time
secondly you seem a little too excited
about this it almost feels like you're
using this like a political chip just a
little bit it seems like you really
enjoy this and don't want to talk about
that clear cluster over in afghanistan
yep
so i don't i would say don't let them
distract you can do both things at the
same time for me right now my obvious
interests lie in afghanistan that to me
seems to be the more
um pressing and horrifying and real no
real clear and present danger the
reality is that afghanistan is a
distraction for the fact that they put
out a list of trump supporters and
they're going after private
communications and the
fascism is coming to the united states
yeah it seems like i'm half kidding by
the way that was like trying to pull
focus away from afghanistan too like
they're like oh or the other way around
yeah there's such a bad press this
afghanistan thing the reality is all
these other things that are popping up
right now it's it's it's it's not really
it's just this it's just the
administration and the democratic party
are just
in a weird state of chaos
and that's it i think the only thing
keeping them together is that they
have really good discipline when it
comes to unity they're just sticking
together
yeah i mean to the point about that list
like that to me suggests more than
anything that
there's a large political angle it's not
about restoring our norms or protecting
our core democracy or whatever those
cliches they're using it's a dragnet
they're just they're they're splunking
to see what they can catch and that's
why no no i think they think they want
to understand uh trump's strategy that's
why scott pressler's on the list because
he registers republicans to vote
why that that's what he does and he
cleans up garbage so they want to
understand the strategy republicans have
for registering new voters they they
they go after trump's uh sp was a pr uh
spokesperson for the campaign they're
just trying to get communications so
they can see how he was running his
campaign they want to get sources
it's a big phishing expedition not
because i think they want to arrest
people necessarily they might get to
that point but they want
free uh free consulting like i mean look
the stuff that they're going to dig up
from these activists costs money for
campaigns and now they're just taking it
all
well why would they go through this
trouble when they already have stuff
like facebook in their pocket helping
them with all their get out there they
don't understand how trump rallies
people and they want to understand his
private metrics they want all of his
data going back from april until after
the election on the election meaning
they want trump all communications
between all these different government
agencies and all the people who worked
in the trump campaign
they want to know every detail of his
campaign
i know it's it's not the point but i i
did laugh when i saw the list of people
because it said all trump children
except for tiffany i was like
what is
poor tiffany what is going on there
she's always left out doesn't make the
list she didn't make the list they're
going after all of them but tiffany
so i mean scary thing though man that
list to me it seems just like kind of a
desperate fishing expedition they're
looking for something damning so they're
just but to your point about pressler
like what does he have to do with any of
this oh but i mean a bunch of people
weren't even there at in on january 6.
and what does their data going back from
april have to do with the insurrection
with the quote unquote insurrection
nothing
they're they're just grabbing a list of
prominent and and influential trump
supporters and they're trying to
intimidate they're trying to get access
to private information
they are going after their political
rivals with the weight of government
this spells the end of
whatever whatever you want to call it i
mean there will be an america in some
fashion but not as we've known it i mean
it can be
it can be we can take it back it'll be
spelled with i have boundless faith in
this country just not its leaders
yeah
i don't know though you know we get to
this point i think
when we see 37.2 percent of the country
want to
secede from their have their regional
unions seed from the greater country
and then you see that the democrats are
willing to pull out
producing a list to actually spy on
american communications and rival
campaigns i'm like man we certainly
crossed that rubicon some time ago you
know it always surprised me not
surprised me i i found it so amusing um
during the trump
years
all the the mountain of news stories and
commentary about how he he's
him and the russians
stole the election with facebook memes
you know oh facebook was weaponized
against us and i was like do you all
forget
the glowing thousand plus word profiles
you wrote after 2008 and 2012 about the
obama campaign's amazing facebook uh
strategy how they work directly with
facebook to figure out where to find i
don't wanna say uh not vulnerable uh
getable voters
and how oh the obama
people they got this they nailed it but
now
using facebook oh my god you had you had
memes about jesus arm wrestling satan
that's how he won that proves it i mean
i still when they talk about how russia
hacked our election and you keep
drilling down you keep asking how did
they
steal the election well
they put out disinformation like that
first of all that's not new secondly
what did the information act was
actually at the museum i'm sorry no the
spy museum in washington dc and they had
an exhibit on like foreign propaganda
and stuff and they had actually the
facebook meme of christ and satan
wrestling it says like if you want trump
to win dislike or whatever if you want
hillary to lose i was like you think
this propaganda swayed and it find me
the american who was on the fence about
hillary until they saw christ's arm
wrestling satan and they're like well
that's convinced me that that convinced
me like first of all that person should
not be allowed to vote that's the first
thing that person's a crazy person
secondly that didn't do it then you
drill down a little further and they go
well they hacked tony podesta's emails
and some other various democratic uh
officials i mean you think that swayed
the election i would argue the fbi and
the 11th hour comey thing hurt her more
which i think they believe which is part
of the reason they hate comey
let's go super chats if you haven't
already smash that like button go to
timcast.com subscribe we're gonna have a
members only segment coming up at
timcast.com and uh share the show if you
like it leave us a good review on
podcast platforms and i'll just mention
something too spotify took down one of
my other my tim pool the temple daily
show they took on an episode i have no
idea why which episode uh it was
i can't remember it was from uh a couple
weeks ago actually
just got an email saying you have
violated the terms and conditions your
episode has been removed and i'm like
for what from like the tim cash channel
yeah
politics it's all politics yeah i have
no idea what i could have said or
anything i have no idea that's that's
like if we're gonna write a new
constitution for the 21st century part
of it has to be that if someone's going
to remove your content they need to give
you an explicit reason why yeah and
there should be some kind of process for
it and a copy of it let's uh let's let's
read some of the super chats we got make
1984 fiction again saying joe biden is
responsible for those deaths so he can
only seek retaliation on himself
wow yeah that's how you were saying how
he's how he freaks out on reporters
that's like what he's doing about the
taliban we were gonna we're gonna go
after with everything we can if they
mess if they hurt us it's like dude you
put us in this position right and the
different talking points which is well
this is why we're leaving also i need to
put in more troops to go get them or we
might put in more troops to go again i'm
like well which one are we doing and i'm
sorry just to one of the things that
i've found particularly disgusting about
all this is his first major press
conference on the disaster over there he
actually blamed the afghans for the
taliban takeover he basically said those
guys are too chicken
whatever word a bunch of cowards they're
weak i'm not going to sacrifice american
sons and daughters to fight a civil war
the afghans won't fight for themselves
i'm like they have been 60 000 60 000
afghan police and national security uh
members of the army have died since 2001
fighting the taliban in their own
backyard with every personal risk to
their life and liberty in their own
backyard they have nowhere to run if it
fails and he blamed them for all of them
and i'll say this too i initially
praised him for pointing out when we
learned that the afghan security forces
just basically abandoned ship i was like
you know what he's right about that why
are we going to fight if they won't and
then we learned about the stripping of
logistics air support bagram and i was
like okay well he stripped here he he
basically whacked him in the leg with a
crowbar and then said look they won't
even fight
all right that's real that's my
president
we got gerald armstrong says biden
committed treason by sending the taliban
a list of american citizens in
afghanistan
i uh uh i i wow that's a that's an issue
with that one yeah providing material
support to an enemy
oh that's right at the very least we
need we need hearings on this we need an
investigation and there's just no who
who is who's in control who is okay
who's signing off on all this yeah when
are they an enemy and when are they uh
an ally like what's the when's the line
drawn because we never declared war on
them and the other thing too is you have
you have the military saying one thing
and the intelligence community's saying
another so somebody is lying or if the
communication is that bad then we still
need an investigation to figure out how
do we get these two groups to actually
talk
all right the one free man says the past
few days have shown us that it is no
longer about america and its enemies
it's about the establishment and its
enemies they have forsaken american
hostages in afghanistan in order to
pursue their political enemies and
secure their power
wow
brutal
the curly afro says military politics is
leviathan
um may see vax's political move by the
high ups to get promoted or in
leadership positions by making troops
get vaccinated a corpsman fell helping
his marines in treating the sick and
injured in afghanistan till valhalla
kinjan says all of us keyboard warriors
need to contact our rep and senders
demanding this change get involved in
your local state and federal elections
stop being the silent majority and get
involved
absolutely yeah
and we got we had some more treason
comments
trash panda says how is this not high
treason forget impeachment bring charges
of high treason against biden the enti
his entire administration including
harris
my guess is because we never declared
war on the taliban so it's like it's
ambiguous if they're even considered
enemies at this point we have a p a
cease fire with them and we're working
with them to get our our troops out as
they i tell you one of the strangest
things today the um um
the i can't remember his name is army
general and biden both of them today
we're talking how we've been in regular
communication with the taliban and and
cooperating with them to help you know
deal with isis and all that and we
sometimes share information with them
but also we can't trust them i was like
whoa
you've been how long have you been
sharing information with the taliban and
why
that's insane
even if it's for the effort of trying to
root out isis isis k whatever why would
you ever was this enemy in my enemy
nonsense is that what this is i think so
that's cool i know because it'll change
from day to day who the enemy we've been
doing this for decades we arm one group
to fight another then both of them end
up coming after us
the same people man
all right doctor doctor says the may
first deadline might have something to
do with being in the middle of ramadan
throughout the years there has been a
couple of ceasefires coordinated with
the taliban because of ramadan
interesting is that when ramadan is i
have no idea
because then there's no
is or is that when does the taliban
strictly observe combat during ramadan i
have no idea i would be surprised if
they did i mean i wouldn't if that's
what people expected yeah monday the
12th of april
is when it started this year oh yeah
oh and it goes for ten days so it was
just after ramadan they were gonna
all right let's see i know it ends may
12th so yeah it was during during
ramadan they were gonna
james rogers says comparing kabul to
saigon is giving in to willful ignorance
ignorance saigon fell two years after we
pulled out stop feeding stupid we lost
pete the peace not war
interesting no i've been saying that for
weeks that people are like this is not
our saigon i'm like you're right this is
far far worse than cybron way worse
i mean not to downplay it but in
comparison saigon got off easy compared
to what afghanistan's saying now that's
again not to minimize what happened in
saigon
here's an important one kf says pelosi
for president
oh god
geez i feel like i'm in the boxing ring
with whoever just said that to me it's
like i mean do i not have any options
here
i mean it's like you can have a you know
a bag of broken glass or some starving
wolverines which one do you want to be
locked in a room with a constitutional
convention it's just a matter of
whipping you need like two more sounds
like 51 of the country or sorry ron paul
constitution man i haven't heard about
that in a long time all right one two
says tim glenn raised 20 million dollars
in 48 hours we all donated this is an
absolutely amazing audience god bless
yes absolutely everybody working that's
that's fantastic dude shout out to glenn
beck man he spoke truth to power when he
was at fox news and i highly recommend
go check out his last episode with fox
because they fired him for calling out
the federal reserve and all the people
the bureaucrats that were trading money
between the revolving doors it was it's
incredible they thought the next day he
got his his release and he was known
what
he started the blaze he knew he was on
his way out i don't know i don't know i
don't think he did he was like what he
got red pill and told everyone and they
were like no he'd been on his way out
for a while he'd been wanting to launch
his own sort of vampire and then i got
to a point where i think he just kind of
uh jerry maguire did yeah edward griffin
on the show and then
just blew it open it was awesome
full full disclosure i i used to work
for him so there's that i love it i see
so much about that dude business editor
at the blaze for a while
so
i can see he's a very he he's a trouble
he genuinely believes in his faith and
he acts out of it
sue pro says the state department is
stonewalling back they won't give him
access to runways also he was warned
they had a meeting about him and are
looking to destroy him
i hadn't heard that but i would not be
surprised because i was as we were
saying before the show there was a i
cannot remember her name i'm drawing a
blank she works for the new york times
she organized two private uh jets to
land and evacuate as many as they could
and they got sent back i think they were
only able to take like a total of four
people they could have fit hundreds on
both of those playing her chats and they
got turned away and she is she's just
beside herself heartbroken yeah she also
raised money to do this private and no
entrepreneurs private enterprise tried
to help out and do his part and a bunch
of paper pushers turned him back that's
good that'll be remembered yeah we have
we have a good question here wicked
lists says tim please help me understand
why people did not leave months ago when
they all knew about the withdrawal
because unlike the united states
intelligence service they had no idea
that the taliban was poised to retake
the entire country
probably that's my guess
i think if there was a general idea that
maybe you should get out you got a
family you got a business huh maybe it's
a recommendation versus oh my god the
taliban now owns the entire country
they've just conquered every major city
and now here we go oh and the united
states is just irish goodbye yeah we got
this uh this uh from arthur madrigal he
says fda approved the vaccine but it is
not available is this true only the
emergency use vaccine available people
have been sending me this bannon said it
it's not true uh they said there's a
letter from the fda that actually goes
into detail about the community vaccine
and the pfizer vaccine people are trying
to claim that it's uh they're two
distinct vaccines the fda's website
literally says
we are approving the vaccine that was
formerly known as the pfizer biotech
vaccine and will now be marketed as
community and the fda letter says
community and the pfizer bioentech
vaccine are interchangeable and the same
thing in the same formulation and for
some reason people are coming out and
claiming it's not true and i don't know
why it's just it's wrong people are
emailing emailing me and i'm like did
you guys even read the letter you sent
me it literally says it's the exact same
formulation but under a different name
it's the same thing
whatever
all right
stephen granger says based on the
information being shown biden should be
forced to resign and be court-martialed
i can also i don't know if you can you
court-martial the president do you i can
also see an argument for having him uh
uh charged with treason we'll just put
it that way
tree he's the commander of the u.s armed
forces but i don't think he can
you know
that's a good question i have no idea
yeah curious now
i will have to look that up i think
can you courtney now you're on a watch
cannot be court-martialed no yeah
according to quora.com yeah i think yeah
i know even though you're the commander
of the forces he's considered a civilian
right he's still civilian the civilian
is commanding the military what is wrong
that's right that's great no civilian
oversight of our u.s armed forces that's
by design i'm all for that which is part
of the reason i was so pissed off about
general milly wising off during the
congressional hearing about white rage
he answers to congress and he was way
out of line when he was like let me i'm
sick of your stupid questions i want to
understand i was like well you you sit
down you answer to them and that's very
intentional
the british seem to have
a civilian leader and a military leader
that co-run the country together i think
they have the prime minister and then
the something else and that's why we
rebelled and and like
what's his name um winston churchill was
the like the military head of the time
but he wasn't they have a house of lords
yeah it's pretty messed up but they have
somebody running the domestic area and
then someone that knows what they're
doing running the military stuff well
where's biden running the military we're
ideally supposed to have the generals
who know what they're doing but they are
all answerable to congress and the
president they answer to the civilians
and that's strictly by design it's
basically straight almost
based on how it was done in rome for a
while before the generals took control
but uh that's i like that setup i want
that setup i don't want the military
kind of acting on its own especially if
you have people like millie who and now
you know off on his own doing critical
race theories or whatever like no no no
you answer to congress and you keep your
mouth shut unless asked a question
here's a good one not you personally
well hey sorry i'm getting ready john
murafa says dr steve turley stopped
using the term rhinos and now uses
diablos democrats in all but label huh
that's that's good well it's not bad
yeah just makes me think of the video
game though
diablo
all right
the what is this the blank podcast the
the null space podcast with ian slater
says glenn beck is now the goat indeed
it's great stuff well hopefully he's uh
it's working out i don't know people are
saying he's getting you know he's
getting blocked or whatever i wouldn't
be surprised i hope he's not but this
has already happened once so i wouldn't
be surprised if it happened again
the wolf says millie and military are
too busy dumping millions in a campaign
to make memes
and anything not in the sjw blm agenda
agenda extremist in the military
crazy
jolin turks says the late johnny carson
did an entire skit about the loser liar
joe biden carson straight up called him
an idiot and he was absolutely correct
yeah if you needed a reminder how long
this guy's been in the game right but
you know i voted for his character i'm
like you've been warned man
come on man
nipple sweat says tim tim kennedy
brought 400 people onto the airfield the
base commander kicked them out and told
tim this isn't the tim kennedy show
what what
so you're not allowed to rescue people
they'll just throw you out i hadn't
heard that i don't have to look
interesting
crazy
all right let's see
jeffrey paris says becca i love your
work based on what you know do you think
the next conservative president should
fire everyone on mahogany row at the
pentagon also ian is your hair starfleet
regulation length
uh i think if there's anything that was
proven by the the trump administration i
hate the term st deep state because
people automatically start conjuring up
conspiracy to resolve it but it is
absolutely true that there is a large
contingent of deeply embedded career
bureaucrats who have been there for
years who have a very specific idea of
how they want things done and they will
work and they admit it they admitted
this during the trump administration
they will work to thwart the president's
agenda if they don't like it simple as
that that's actually what i think when i
think deep state i don't think that you
know it's sort of like meaning of the
bilderbergs are going to get together
blah blah blah but yeah no there are
career bureaucrats who are like i don't
like this so we're going to link to the
press we're going to obscure this or
that i mean they like general straight
up lie to uh donald president trump when
he ordered twice he ordered saying we're
withdrawing from syria they lied to him
about the numbers
to just simply get around not having to
withdraw everyone from assyria that's
deep state and they lied to the american
people they lied to the american people
and they then come out a minute who was
that the guy anonymous for new york
times uh miles taylor straight up
admitted i work in the white house and i
am actively thwarting the president's
agenda
that happens this has actually happened
with several administrations so to the
question i think if anything was learned
from last president yes someone's gonna
have to start cleaning house i don't
know how that goes about what that looks
like it's very hard to remove people
once they're embedded it was what trump
was famous for
firing people firing he was terrible at
firing people when he was the president
though his tagline is you're fired and
he couldn't fire anyone around him it
was amazing in fact some of the people
he promoted were terrible
yeah
elizabeth carmella comedian says when i
saw glenn's stream late last night from
the middle east i myself donated to the
nazarene fund that man is a true patriot
i have so much respect and admiration
for him and what he's doing if you can
donate please do yeah man i remember i
got invited to go on glenn's show they
flew me out to texas and sat down and
talked to him for quite a bit because we
did like a couple different shows in one
sitting because he's got like the radio
show the podcast whatever and i thought
it was absolutely fantastic he's calm
rational reasonable we we had arguments
we uh with disagreements and it ended
with a handshake and he was like you
know you you did great work and i was
like yeah it was absolutely fantastic
big fan of glenn he's a great guy
he's a hell of a showman oh yeah
definitely
and they have this massive movie studio
yeah
he uh he considers himself he doesn't
consider himself he is very
intentionally modeled himself after
orson welles he wants to be a sort of
auteur
renaissance man bringing back various
arts and stuff he loves he loves orson
welles like adores orson welles he
intentionally he named it mercury radio
arts after orson welles's uh own
production studio which was mercury oh
yeah yeah he just loves the man mercury
and he loves walt disney
sonny james says the only reason america
won the revolution was because the
british public wasn't interested in
funding it despite what hollywood
narratives tell us it wasn't because we
fought the greatest revolution ever
scares me as this admin focused on us
um
we won the revolution for a lot of
reasons yeah there were several factors
but uh i think the french was probably
one of the biggest huge one because what
what if what actually happened is that
the conflict in the colonies was
essentially more war for the british
when they're already at war in europe
they couldn't handle it oh god
it was also king george had lost his
freaking mind and was a horrible
commander-in-chief really yeah he was
going insane at the time that was
actually a huge issue
that was engulfing a lot of british
politics at the time and was very
distracting to the overall war effort
the the british had no stomach for a war
within the americans oh turn about just
let them go turn about as fair
we're getting slapped in the face by
karma
okay all right let's see i'm just
kidding
i don't i can't speak to biden's mental
health i'm not a doctor he's not my
patient but history rhymes and if there
was a revolution today in the united
states and we had biden as the commander
trying to preserve the union preserve
the union your main job
oh god
pardon those people imagine american
civil war with biden
it would be it would be terrible you
live in an interesting time at least abe
lincoln that's a curse was obsessed with
preserving the union
you just cursed me
all right uh
jasper says tim please look into the
ezekiel 38 prophecy we may be seeing it
take shape in real time the stage is
being set the players are moving into
place we are really living in
unprecedented unprecedented times
interesting interesting unprecedented
for america
i wouldn't say it's unprecedented in
world history
i mean far worse has happened to far
greater far larger civilizations
true you know
generally there's in a longer span of
time it seems like we have
very quickly learned how to yeah
airplanes changes a lot because you
literally you can get chips microchips
that's the game changer plastic a lot of
it
invested in plastics
lmv says tim i live in new zealand our
prime minister did a press conference on
the attack in kabul and was super
cryptic saying that new zealand will be
part of an attack or invasion of
afghanistan oh my god okay so maybe it
was intentional with what troops i
thought they're all locked up in new
zealand new zealand has troops
they do they do no no they're great
they've worked they worked closely with
us in a lot of the coalition efforts
commandos
i love new zealanders right yeah about
uh biden said we will you know we will
hunt you down
and to me i was just like oh is is that
him saying like we're going to be
sending in troops to reinvade
afghanistan now we've already put in
more than double
troops into afghanistan now than we had
earlier this year and then they're
hoping everyone will forget about it the
news will start talking about other
things and then they'll be quietly
deploying more and more soldiers to
afghanistan
amazing in it
i mean at some point this is going to
sap the will from the actual armed
forces like what do you do you're gonna
you're gonna actually have to talk about
morale in the u.s military
i can't imagine it's it's doing well
i can imagine that this is going to have
a long-term
hit on it and that'll take some years to
recover
i'm not saying it's all going to fall
apart and people are going to abandon
their posts or whatever but i we need to
make sure we look at this before
yeah it's coming up on 800 000 military
servicemen weren't vaccinated i think
it's 1.4 million total 800 000 of them
have had yet to be vaccinated as of like
yesterday or day before and they're
going to force it by what i don't know
what the date is that they said the 31st
four days from now five days from now
so that's another and if they don't want
to do it you know talk about morale
rory shively
with um
eight clown face emojis
that's about where i'm at
he's a funny guy
all right brian knowles says you said
bagram air base seemed intentional i've
been thinking the same thing every
common sense thing to do done backwards
biden wrote the first patriot act maybe
arming terrorists
oh i don't know huh
i mean to the conversation we're having
about
the riot and holding the rioters and all
that i mean
we we've been saying no what was it for
the war on terror you know what did we
get out of it well we got one thing we
got an explosion of their surveillance
state on us so that's great now the
government as we know not just the
american government governments in
general do like pretenses to get more
control
what does afghanistan do does that give
people more control does it give them
less
that's obviously the media is going to
go full gung-ho with like biden as a
true president once he starts sending in
the troops and once all these other
countries start bolstering troops
he's going to rescue them from trump's
botched escape
i think a lot of people are
underestimating how sapped a lot of
americans feel after this of 20 years i
don't think we talk about we're going to
put more troops and they do it quietly
like you were saying that's one thing
but a big grand we got to do this
america i don't there's not going to be
support people don't want it i don't
want it no but the media will say they
do and the polls will come out and the
polls will will ask very like funny
questions like do you think it would be
bad if babies are killed in afghanistan
and they say yes i do like they support
the war yeah with a sampling size of
like 130 people right
98 percent of americans all from dc on
like k street
[Laughter]
well the average income
you look it up it's like 406 thousand
dollars a year
who are these people they're bowling we
surveyed 130 defense contractors the
average job is halliburton and boeing
yeah man there's so much money do you
want to deploy more americans to go
fight nation build i don't 100 yes we
pulled one guy it's the ceo of lockheed
no but it's like if there's no will for
an americans are actually opposed to it
that comes back at the voting booth you
saw that yeah
hold on it comes back to voting
but what is biden you think biden's
gonna get a second term i don't think
he's gonna last his first term so biden
can come in and be like oh
deploy a hundred thousand
your
troops you know you get if they didn't
get the vaccine to go to afghanistan
and then americans are going to be like
get them out get them out
no one will have the will to do it
republicans will sit in their hands come
2024 they'll vote for someone else and
go yay and then we'll have three years
of troops in the middle east but you're
forgetting 2022 which democrats are
terrified of i don't know if they wanted
right i'm saying there's if there's
anything everyone's not going to do
anything i'm just saying if there's one
thing both parties love it's holding
power and gaining more power and if they
know they're going to get wiped out on a
landslide in 2022 i think they they
won't go what are the republicans going
to do well that's always there they're
going to get in and go and then
they're all going to get in and they're
going to have the house and then kevin
mccarthy is going to be like slow down
there democrats and then mitch mcconnell
is going to be like
crouch and that's all they're going to
do nah i disagree on
mccarthy yes
i'm generally i'm generally supportive
of mcconnell i have been impressed with
he's he's a master parliamentarian and
he has made so many gains in the
judiciary i think people always sell
them a little short right the problem
with conservatives is that
they're uh
imagine you're playing a game of
football and uh you tell your team to
run to your to the end zone and defend
it from there and then the damn like the
other team is like okay and they
casually walk to to the red zone it's
like
why would you let them do that that's
republicans
they don't they don't they don't fight
on the cultural issues that shape our
country they think if we just get a
judge we're fine okay then
congratulations because in 10 years all
the judges are going to be ultra woke
and you're going to be like well this
one's only a little woke because you're
not actually doing anything to to defend
your values or fight back i mean that's
i don't know if
i would blame mcconnell for that
explicitly i mean you can only blame him
so much if the people he gets through
aren't very good he still got him
through and the best of the crop but the
thing i will say that you're absolutely
right on is that social issues have long
been put in the back burner and stuff
like the republican party has basically
tolerated pro-lifers for the last since
roe v wade is it just a necessary part
of the coalition they don't care what
they think or what they believe yep they
haven't tried anything to like over
democrats are coming out demanding
universal health care in a great new
deal what are republicans demanding
tax cuts
same thing i mean look at what the
infrastructure bill that's not even
going to get held up
geez 6 trillion it threw four four i
believe it was a one separate two built
two separate bills 1.2 and 3.5 so
upwards of 5 trillion
because we have that money what was the
6 trillion number that got knocked
around yesterday i mean maybe got
revised upwards did they add any writers
to it no i don't know
oh this is a six trillion just put
anything just make it 10. this is
interesting right here cryptic says the
supreme court just overruled the invic
the eviction ban
i had seen that actually kavanaugh was
the wrote the opinion on i haven't had a
chance to read it though did he write f
you biden i already said this why am i
saying it twice
because biden doesn't remember the first
time
and so if if the supreme court can say
this is illegal and biden says i'll do
it again what's to stop him from just
doing it again and again and again uh
you know what enforcement mechanisms are
there supreme court doesn't happen they
just take them back to the court i mean
the president already said once he's
like that'll get sorted out in the court
and you know in a couple months but
until then people will be safe i'm like
so
legislation by tangling things up in the
judiciary like that's not a way to
legislate
i think what it really means is that if
you are a landlord in any capacity you
can now just disregard the illegal
decrees from the president because they
have no merit in the country and if you
have to go to court you'd win
because you're going to be like here's
the supreme court your honor is going to
go um going to court is how long is that
going to take yep i mean a lot of people
don't have that time
i think it basically just means you can
ignore biden's fake eviction illegal
eviction man yeah but what do you tell
the squatters
you break you kick them out what do you
mean i mean what happens is no the
president's on my side he says i can
stay
you call the police
what but what law are the police
enforcing you're evicting them i know
but if the president has already put a
moratorium on that supreme court has
already said it's not doesn't exist but
then the president does it again
that's why i'm asking like what's the
enforcement well it's it's an issue of
whether or not the police are are
anarcho-tyranists
and i'd imagine they are in which case
the cops are going to go to you and go
sorry i can't help you but then rest
assured if you try to do anything to
defend your property they'll arrest you
on the spot probably
yup abolish the police
that's right
all right let's see
jessica cora says we left hundreds of
portable biometric scanners with the
fingerprint and eye scans of over 50 000
afghanistan military officials whoa
that's true you've heard that right yep
we were documenting and recording
everything about the afghans we worked
with in the taliban got all that
information
fingerprints eye scans everything cool
wow yeah a lot of people are mentioning
that scotus has lifted the eviction
moratorium but like i said like we were
saying i don't know if it matters
because biden illegally did it in the
first place why does the supreme court
need to say it twice
right that's the thing that i didn't get
the supreme court really didn't even say
it the first time
and i said it twice but this is where i
get into this weird area of like wait a
minute the supreme court there's usually
this assumption the supreme court ruled
and that's that now they've done it
twice what to your point what happens if
binding comes back another time and says
well no i said they tweak it a little
bit that's what cuomo was doing keep
tweeting
yep he'll tweak it a little bit he'll
say oh now we're gonna do uh an eviction
suspension so
you can follow eviction but it can't be
enforced for six months it's so funny
how fast they turn from no rule no law
of the land to
more like a guideline on the land more
like guidelines
all right let's see
christopher bell says well you have
someone that's on the other side of your
argument like dan crenshaw we'd love to
have dan crenshaw you know the big
challenges with getting politicians on
the show every every time we hit up one
of these politicians they're like oh
we're fans we'd love to come on the show
or oh definitely it'd be great send an
email to this person and we'll set it up
and then we do and then the person
doesn't respond back or responds back
with like yeah we'll figure out the
dates and then they never respond back
sounds like don't waste
yes oh is he necessarily pro stay in
afghanistan i think he is i thought he
just wanted a small residual force as
security right small residual force i
think like syria and but i actually have
said that myself like i think we should
have never gone into afghanistan but if
we have because we've had people on the
show have said this we need a small we
need commanders intelligence logistics
but a very small group with drone
support and we're done and i'm like i'll
take that if it prevents this if it
means we're getting all of our troops
out we're not going to waste time on
this but we'll have to keep a little bit
i'll draw it down substantially i like
the sound of that it's so crazy to
remember or to think in terms of
everything that's happening now that at
the height of the iraq war and even to
the dra the lead up to obama withdrawing
from iraq afghanistan was always the
good war the justified war and now here
we are
man i don't know but i will tell you
this we're gonna have a members only
podcast episode coming up at around 11
or so p.m at timcast.com so go to
timcast.com become a member check out
all the awesome articles we have we have
a really great uh uh story
uh uh on the ground covering actually
maybe we'll talk about this for the for
the for the member segment we'll talk
about some of the original reporting we
got people protesting and risking their
job saying they expect to be fired in
the next couple of weeks because the
mandates in new york go to timkes.com
check it out don't forget to like smash
the like button subscribe to this
channel you can follow the show at tim
cast irl we put up clips on all the
different platforms and you can follow
me personally at tim cast do you want to
shout out anything beckett
no my mom i don't know
you want to shout out your mom no i mean
hi mom
don't make it weird
hey just follow me on twitter beckett
adams there you go there we go
some nice uh self-promotion right good
to see you man all right thanks for
having me follow me at ian crossland at
ian crossland.net if you'd like to get
get to my nexus point um hey i hope
you're feeling all right that was a
rough show tonight this is brutal stuff
and i actually do know how to do a shout
out on like beckett you guys should
follow me on twitter at sourpatchlids as
i'm approaching the number of followers
as sourpatch kids very excited about
this this is my goal in life and i
appreciate all your help
thanks for hanging out everybody i know
this was this is it's it's so brutal
because i'm like you know some days we
have fun stories uh that are like still
politically relevant and everything but
usually
you know it's always so negative so
go to timkes.com if you want to hear
more of that thanks for hanging out
we'll see y'all there bye guys
you